ne démarre idriss touristique bonjour
bonsoir mathieu estime jourdain est avec
nous en salle des conférences bonsoir
steve comment cette audition doit-elle
se dérouler et puis surtout que peut-on
en attendre pas de clash un thomas c'est
pas tellement le genre de la maison ici
au sénat vous le savez bien non ce qu'on
veut ici c'est la vérité toute la vérité
rien que la vérité parce qu'évidemment
quatre jours après le match ce match
real liverpool de ligue des champions et
bien non c'est toujours pas ou n'est
toujours pas suffisamment sur ce qui
s'est réellement passé la ligne du
gouvernement on la connaît la ligne
officielle de gérald darmanin c'est de
dire eh bien que s'il ya eu des
débordements la responsabilité incombe
principalement aux supporters anglais
pas tous les supporters anglais
évidemment dans ceux qui sont venus aux
abords du stade de france sans billet ou
bien munis de faux billets gérald
darmanin qui a avancé ce chiffre qui a
beaucoup fait parler il y aurait entre
30 et 40 mille fraudeurs qui se serait
dépassé aux abords du stade de france un
chiffre qui est difficilement vérifiable
c'est un chiffre qui a été contesté un
par un certain nombre d'observateurs il
faut donc s'attendre ici dans quelques
instants maintenant une bataille un peu
technique à une bataille évidemment de
chiffres on va assister sa a6 et a7
audition avec beaucoup d'attention il
faut aussi savoir que en toile de fond
il ya une dimension évidemment politique
la majorité ici au sénat c'est la droite
c'est le centre et les élections
législatives c'est dans douze jours
maintenant très exactement évidemment il
faut jamais oublier cette échéance
électorale qui joue qui sera donc menée
par le président de la commission des
lois le sénateur et l'air françois noël
buffet et par le priant de commission de
la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication
qui chapeaute aussi la thématique des
sports sénateurs centristes laurent
lafon matthieu croissandeau on a tous en
tête et d'ailleurs on en avait fait un
débat ici même dans ceux dans l'émission
sens public lundi soit cette conférence
de presse à l'issue de voix là d'une
première réunion avec toutes les parties
prenantes de l'uefa la fédération
la ministre des sports évidemment gérald
darmanin on avait trouvé gérald darmanin
un peu désinvolte voilà le terme que moi
en tout cas j'avais employé est ce qu'on
peut imaginer une autre attitude là
devant les sénateurs et on peut imaginer
il faut l'imaginer en tout cas pour lui
parce que ça n'a pas convaincu il a tenu
cette soul et il est allé à cette
réunion qui avait lieu au ministère des
sports alors qu'il n'avait pas prévu d'y
aller dans un premier temps puisque aux
fonds gérés darmanin aurait bien aimé
c'est à dire ce qu'il a fait pendant
tout le week-end dire c'est une affaire
sportive c'est pas une affaire qui conte
qui concerne le ministère l'intérieur
évidemment ça n'a pas tenu donc il s'est
rendu à cette réunion il a fait une
conférence de presse après avec monique
oudéa castéra la ministre des sports la
nouvelle mine et des sports le soir même
elle s'est invitée au 20h de tf1
normalement ça aurait dû clore cette
polémique clore les questions qu'on
pourrait se poser sur le fiasco est pas
du tout pourquoi parce que j'ai un
darmanin s'en tient à stallings la faute
à steve a expliqué aulas photo 30 à
40000 supporters anglais munis de faux
billets ou sans billet le problème c'est
que cinq convainc personne à commencer
par l'opposition bien sûr mais aussi les
anglais qui demandent des excuses par la
voix du patron du club de liverpool par
la voix de gary lineker vous souvenez de
cette ancienne
l'anglais kaki est twitté pendant en
français s'il vous plaît pendant la
conférence de presse de gérard darmanin
tout ça c'est des conneries en français
dans le texte bullshits s'il avait pu le
dire en anglais ouais c'est ça ne
convainc pas grand monde et y compris
des spécialistes et y compris les
reporters qui était sur place des
différentes rédactions et qui n'ont pas
vu ses trente à quarante et une
personnes avancé parmi notre attention
parce que l'ambiance a changé c'est
devenu un vrai sujet polémique politique
la gauche s'en est saisie en 10 ans la
faute aux policiers qui ont mal réagi
qui ont mal un tel qu'ils sont mal
intervenus l'extrême droite s'en est
saisie en 10 ans la fois autour
délinquants il se dit migration de ces
quartiers sensibles qui ont gâché la
fête et devant lesquelles le
gouvernement les forces de l'ordre n'ont
rien fait et puis et bananes macron
s'est fâché ce matin en conseil alors
justement olivier grégoire là la
nouvelle porte parole du gouvernement
qui s'est exprimé à l'issue de ce
conseil des ministres allait
effectivement
insisté là dessus est ce qu'on a le son
dolby augouard alors regardez en même
temps les images des sénateurs qui sont
en train et les gens disent qu'ils sont
en train de s'installer voilà on est on
est à quelques mètres d'ici donc
auditions menées je m'appelle par le
président de la commission des lois et
le président de la commission
culture je recherche le titre exact
éducation et communication qui s'occupe
aussi des sports qui lui est en visio je
pense que c'est en train de démarrer on
écoute à olivet prévoir juste après
évidemment et on débriefera après cette
audition
quelques photographies
voilà nos confrères font leur travail
merci messieurs merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
à la mini
laurent lafon président de la commission
de la culture et moi même avons décidé
d'organiser votre audition
laurent lafon contre sa volonté et et
est retenu hors de cette salle mais ils
participent parfois de des
visioconférences et prendra dans
quelques instants la parole
quelques mots d'introduction si vous me
le permettez avant que nous puissions
vous laisser vous exprimer et puis
ensuite
chacun des collègues parlementaires
présents ou en visioconférence se
signalant par avance pourra
poser des questions qu'ils souhaitent en
indiquant la règle du jeu habituel c'est
que deux minutes par question et par
intervention nous paraissent un temps
suffisant pour pouvoir formuler les
questions vous souhaitez
samedi soir dernier de graves incidents
qui n'ont heureusement pas fait de
blessés graves se sont produits en marge
du match de la finale de la ligue des
champions qui opposait au stade de
france les équipes de liverpool et du
real de madrid
la gestion de cet événement a été
unanimement qualifiée soit de
scandaleuse voire même par certains
responsables politiques dont une
nationale
c'est donc à la fois pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé pour démêler les
responsabilités des différents
intervenants et pour tirer les
enseignements qui s'imposent de cet
événement afin que de tels incidents ne
se reproduisent plus que mon collègue
laurent lafon président la culture et
culture et moi même avons souhaité
conjointement vous entendre
vous vous êtes tous deux exprimé
publiquement
mais les explications fournies font
encore aujourd'hui l'objet de critiques
fortes notamment de la part de personnes
qui étaient présentes sur les lieux
premier point concernant les causes des
incidents vous avez un indic incriminé
dès samedi soir je vous cite des
milliers de supporters britanniques sans
billet ou avec de faux billets on aurait
forcé des entrées et parfois violente et
les stadiers
les responsabilités imputée aux
supporters britanniques ou la
responsabilité pardon imputée aux
supporters britanniques est toutefois
contestée notamment par les officiers de
la police de liverpool qui étaient
présents sur place comme observateurs
nombre d'observateurs ont noté au
contraire le calme de ces supporters qui
auraient contribué à l'absence
d'incident grave les services de
renseignements de la préfecture avait
t-il de ce point de vue il a mal
apprécié ce que serait l'attitude de ses
supporters
vous avez également tous deux évoqué un
phénomène massif de faux billets de
l'ordre de 30000 à 40000
depuis leur le f a indiqué que seuls
deux mille huit cents billets avaient
été identifiés comme falsifiés lors du
passage des portiques ce chiffre pouvant
d'ailleurs être gonflé par des problèmes
techniques
comment ces fraudes qui serait donc bien
plus limité qu'annoncé en tous les cas
selon l'uefa
aurait-elle pu jouer le rôle déterminant
que vous leur prêtez dans les incidents
de samedi soir
par ailleurs la presse s'est fait l'écho
d'une note durance et de renseignement
de la division nationale de lutte contre
le hooliganisme vous alertant dès le
mercredi 25 mai sur de possibles risques
liés à des billets falsifiés et la
présence de nombreux supporters sans
bruit sans billet
cette alerte at elle été dûment prises
on compte
encore été évoqué la gestion du prêt
filtrage à l'arrivée du rer d et
notamment des fils en nombre insuffisant
et un manque de personnel alors que
d'après ce que rapportent les médias le
dispositif était fluide à la sortie du
rer b qui étaient en grève ce jour-là
il ne s'agissait pas d'une circonstance
imprévue les organisations syndicales de
la ligne b avait fait état dès le mardi
24 mai leur intention de perturber le
déroulement de la finale de la ligue des
champions en cessant le travail
dans ces conditions comment expliquer
que le dispositif n'est pas été adapté
en conséquence est que les moyens n'est
pas été redéployée à la sortie du rer d
d'où semble t'il sont douces ont
semble-t-il arriver une majorité de
spectateurs enfin l'intrusion de
riverains du stade de france a également
été évoquée tout comme des agressions et
des vols de spectateurs à la fin du
match sans qu'on en sache davantage à ce
stade pouvez vous préciser le nombre
d'arrestations de poursuite de plaintes
liées à cet événement donc de procédure
engagée et qu'elle a été la suite donnée
à ces procédures la plupart des
personnes arrêtées auraient été vous
pose la question des sans-papiers est-ce
le cas et comment l'expliquez vous
deuxième point la question se pose de la
responsabilité des différents
intervenants et notamment des services
placés sous l'arbre responsabilité le
rapport qui a été adressée par le préfet
de police à qui vous a été reçue par le
préfet de police au soir du 29 mai
semble exonérer la police de toute
responsabilité
l'organisation de la ligue des champions
relève de la responsabilité de l'uefa
mais c'est bien sûr celle de la
préfecture de police qui est pointé du
doigt notamment par son usage qui aurait
été qualifié de massifs et d'incriminer
des gaz lacrymogènes qui aurait touché
des familles des enfants des personnes
de bonne foi muni du billet valide et
qui pour certaines d'entre elles n'ont
jamais pu entrer dans le stade
il est essentiel que vous nous apportez
des explications circonstanciées sur le
schéma d'intervention des forces de
l'ordre qui avaient été retenus pour cet
événement et notamment et notamment
sur les consignes qui ont été données
aux forces en matière d' usage des gaz
lacrymogènes et la répartition des
missions
entre les agents de la direction de la
sécurité publique et les unités de
forces mobiles
la presse s'est également fait l'écho du
fait que la doctrine d'usagé en la
matière pourrait être modifiée en
prévision des grands événements sportifs
à venir nous les connaissons tous ils
seront importants l'année prochaine et
l'année suivante est ce le cas
enfin il est également il a également
été rapportée par un certain nombre de
journalistes que ceux ci avaient été
contraints de supprimer des images
qu'ils avaient prises des événements
ces faits sont avérés
des consignes en ce sens sont
effectivement donné aux forces de
l'ordre c'était le cas comment les
justifier
enfin s'agissant notamment de
l'intrusion de riverains de jeunes
riverains des exactions qu'ils auraient
commises à l'issue du match comment
expliquer que ceux ci n'ait pas été
repéré en amont par les forces de police
et que des dispositions particulières
n'est pas été prises pour sécuriser la
sortie du stade à la fin de celui-ci
enfin la france a déjà par le passé
accueilli des manifestations sportives
de cette ampleur sans qu'elle de lieux
d'ailleurs aux débordements dont
malheureusement le monde entier a été
témoin samedi soir
nous nous interrogeons et c'est pour ça
que nous sommes ici cet après midi sur
cette situation sur la réalité de ce qui
s'est passé d'abord pour savoir
effectivement et comprendre ces
événements en tirer les conséquences
nécessaires évidemment mais aussi parce
que dans quelques temps en quelques mois
notre pays organisera accueillera la
coupe du monde de rugby en 2023 et par
ailleurs en 2024 et jeux olympiques et
les jeux paralympiques
voilà mais lui je me suis ministre j'ai
recollé les propos introductifs je vais
des titres dc la parole tout de suite au
président laurent lafon
mais le monsieur le griot mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je suis désolé de ne pas être
parmi vous mais je suis contre l
isolement suite un test positif je
remercie à mon tour pour leur présence
cet après midi au sénat le sujet sera le
gardien midi l'intérieur est madame
amélie blé à castéra ministre des sports
et des jeux olympiques et paralympiques
je ne doute pas madame la ministre que
nous aurons prochainement l'occasion de
nous revoir - terry des plus avant
l'ensemble des dossiers qui relèvent de
votre ministère mais je saisis cette
occasion puisque je crois que c'est
votre première venue au sénat en tout
cas dans le cadre de vos nouvelles
fonctions pour vous féliciter pour votre
nomination comme l'a indiqué le
président de la commission des lois la
gravité des dysfonctionnements se sont
déroulées samedi à proximité immédiate
de paris dans le futur stade olympique
ne pouvait nous laisser indifférent une
compétition prestigieuse entaché des
milliers de personnes retarder ou
empêcher d'accéder au stade certaines
molesté des actes de délinquance en
grand nombre le sénat se devait d
exercer son pouvoir de contrôle devant
ce que l'on peut qualifier de fiasco
deux ans avant les jeux olympiques et un
an avant la coupe du monde de rugby
nous avons de nombreuses questions à
vous poser
comme a commencé à le faire le président
du fai parmi lesquels à mon sens une
s'impose ces incidents et est il très
lisible et donc évitables il est
important pour nous de savoir la nature
des échanges et des décisions
éventuelles prises par les différentes
autorités et à une forme consortium du
stade de france ratp et sncf avant la
finale alors que vous saviez depuis
plusieurs jours que deux événements
allaient fortement impacté
l'organisation de matches la grève sur
le rer b connue depuis plusieurs jours
et la sauce billetterie identifiés par
la division nationale de la lutte contre
le hooliganisme dans une note en date du
25 mai soit trois jours avant la finale
je rappelle que le 13 novembre 2021
c'est-à-dire il ya à peine six mois le
match france- kazakhstan dans le cadre
des éliminatoires de la coupe du monde
avait été dès l'école est délocalisée au
parc des princes car des travaux étaient
programmés sur la ligne b du rer les
risques de saturation d autres moyens de
transport et en particulier la ligne d
avait été considéré comme trop important
à l'époque
allait pas encore la grève de la ratp
sur cette même ligne a eu des effets
similaires à ce qui était redouté à
l'automne dernier avec des rapports très
important sur la ligne d du rer est ce
que l'hypothèse d'un report de la finale
a été envisagée compte tenu de la grève
annoncée est ce que le risque de
saturation a été suffisamment évalués à
défaut de pouvoir reporter la rencontre
des mesures exceptionnelles ont elles
été envisagée comme par exemple la
réquisition de conducteur sur la ligne b
la régulation des flux en amont de la
ligne d à paris-nord où la mise en place
d'un système de transport alternatif par
bus comment avez vous essayé de prévenir
ce risque prévisible de saturation
concernant l'accès au stade de france
ensuite vous avez indiqué que de
nombreux faux billets avaient été
diffusées et que c'est le club de
liverpool qui avait demandé
l'établissement des billets papier que
vous avez estimé aisément falsifiable ma
question est donc la suivante qu'elles
ont quêté la nature de vos échanges avec
l'uefa sur ce point et pourquoi ne pas
avoir exigé de l'uefa l'établissement
des billets électroniques à falsifiable
là encore le risque était identifiée et
rien pourtant ne semble avoir été fait
pour les éviter je laisserai mes
collègues vous poser d'autres questions
mais je ne serai évident et l'attitude
qu'a suscitée chez nombre de sénateurs
cet échec de samedi dernier quant à
l'organisation des jeux olympiques à
paris en 2004 quelle leçon allez-vous en
retirer
le organiser la finale de la champion s
league un an avant la coupe du monde de
rugby et deux ans avant les jeux
olympiques avaient valeur de test le
test montre que manifestement ne sommes
pas encore prêts à faire face à toutes
les situations
l'originalité revendiquer des jeux de
paris tient au fait que l'événement
devrait être autant dans les stades que
dans les vues avec un immense
rassemblement populaire
je pense en particulier à la cérémonie
d'ouverture qui doit rassembler
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes le long de la seine n'est-il
pas nécessaire compte tenu des
événements de samedi dernier de
réfléchir un format plus raisonnable
pour éviter un nouveau fiasco qui
nuirait à l'image de notre grille madame
messieurs les ministres je vous cède la
parole enfin si le président buffet peut
pas reprendre peut-être que on peut
transmettre tout de suite le la parole
au ministre
celui-ci vous en prie
madame la ministre le cheikh hamidi
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois le se présente la commission
des affaires culturelles mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
ce avec le souci de la transparence et
du sens des responsabilités que nous
vous présentons devant vous avec le
profond respect pour la représentation
nationale et ses prérogatives et un
gouvernement qui n'a rien à cacher et
nous nous réjouissons du pouvoir qu'ils
nous aient laissé c'est à dire du temps
nécessaire pour expliquer ce qui s'est
passé samedi soir lors du match de
finale de ligue des champions qui
opposait real madrid liverpool nous
étions d'ailleurs tous les deux madame
la ministre et moi-même
il est évident que cette fête du sport a
été gâchée et que nous regrettons très
sincèrement les débordements
parfois inacceptables qui aux yeux dont
nous allons en assurant notre
responsabilité explicite est devant vous
le déroulement j'espère monsieur présent
la commission des lois se présentait
plus aux affaires culturelles répondre
aux questions en tout cas nous allons
nous répartir évidemment ces questions
introductive dans la présentation que je
vais vous faire dans quelques instants
dont je vous remercie d'avoir accepté
d'ailleurs qu'elle soit 7 devant les
sénateurs je veux aussi dire que pour
ceux qui nous regardent sera sur les
réseaux sociaux pour ceux qui le
souhaitent il est également évident
que pour les fans de football dont nous
sommes un certain nombre et pour avoir
été arbitre de football pendant de très
nombreuses années l'image négative de ce
match est une blessure pour notre fierté
nationale il est évident que les choses
auraient pu être mieux organisé
avons-nous éviter le pire oui pouvons
nous mieux organisés à vaulruz aurions
nous pu anticiper davantage sans doute
responsable de mon administration je
regrette très sincèrement des attaques
dont était la cible les fonctionnaires
de la république qui sont sous ma
responsabilité
comme ministre il est tout à fait normal
que je réponde aux médias aux
parlementaires avec l'éthique de
l'opinion est seul et lâche je crois se
défausse sur leurs subordonnés je veux
donc ici dire la confiance que
l'ensemble des personnes que j'ai eu
peur de commander depuis deux ans
ministère de l'intérieur et complète
pour ma part
comme le disait le président mitterrand
signé point d'honneur sans
difficulté je suis devant vous
évidemment que la ministre des sports
pour pouvoir détailler cette soirée si
on ne permet tait voyons déjà le
contexte général qui a évoqué notamment
monsieur président de la commission des
affaires culturelles je voudrais ici
rappeler qu'un ministre des sports que
la finale de la champions league devait
se dérouler à saint pétersbourg et que
suite à la situation géopolitique était
décidé de la situer dans un autre stade
la france était candidate pour
accueillir cette champions league dont
je rappelle et vous l'avez dit monsieur
présidents des commissions des lois que
l'organisation de cet événement en
revient à l'uefa et à la fédération
nationale la fédération française de
football
normalement dans les finales tels que
sap et hambourg aurait dû l'organiser
ces 18 mois en général pour le cahier
des charges verrines au public pour
organiser une telle finale la france y
compris les pouvoirs publics bien
évidemment et en lien avec la fédération
française et usa a organisé cette
manifestation en trois mois de plus vous
l'avez dit une grève ratp quelques jours
auparavant a été annoncée qui a déplacé
massivement les supporters des lignes du
rer b vers le rer d je veux ici dire que
la difficulté principale que nous ayons
eu le premier enchaînement négatif de
cette soirée
c'est que le flux sur le rer d a été 3 5
fois plus important selon les chiffres
de la sncf que lors d'un match de
football qui amène du monde à le stade
de france on va dire de façon normale
prenons comme étalon quelques jours
auparavant la finale de la coupe de
france qui pourtant d'ailleurs a été
testé de manière plus négative par les
services de lutte contre le hooliganisme
que la finale de champions league
puisque le bail des notes de
renseignements aux sportifs du ministère
de l'intérieur et pour ceux qui ont pris
le rer d et le rer b pour aller au stade
de france chacun se passera et colorée
rb effet si j'ose dire pour ça avec une
plus grande sortie plusieurs sorties et
un plus grand espace pour accéder au
stade de france et que le rer d et plus
étroit avec un goulot d'étranglement en
dessous de l'autoroute qui amène
directement effectivement au stade de
france singulièrement pour les tribunes
britannique car nous verrons que les
débordements et les difficultés dans le
lieu que devant les tribunes britannique
quel était le dispositif de sécurité est
question première que vous m'avez posé
monsieur le président il ya eu six mille
huit cents policiers et gendarmes et
quelques dizaines de satan pompiers
déployés pour assurer la sécurité de
l'événement c'est l'événement qui depuis
je suis à l'intérieur événement sportif
bien évidemment à mobiliser le plus de
policiers et de gendarmes parmi ceux ci
il ya eu des ce qu'on appelle les ufm
les unités de forces mobiles à peu près
80 crs ou gendarmes mobiles qui ont été
prédisposés dans le périmètre du stade
de france 18 fm on reverra le fait que
ce jamais le stade de france en tout cas
depuis je suis mise intérieur d'un
inconnu autant je rappelle que suite à
la note de renseignement justement
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois qui prévoyait à très nombreux
nombre d'anglais sans ticket ou quelques
centaines avec des faux billets nous y
reviendrons plus tous ceux qui
viendraient à paris pour pouvoir
supporter leur équipe le support
l'entraîneur du club de liverpool ayant
dit lui-même qu'il fallait en grand
nombre venir même sans billet appareils
supportés liverpool a été décidé de fan
zones l'une cours de vincennes très
éloignées donc du stade de france où il
ya eu jusqu'à 40000 personnes
essentiellement des supporters anglais
ou des supporters du club de liverpool
il peut y avoir des français qui sont
allés dans cette femme donne bien
évidemment
et puis un qui est juste à côté du stade
de france la salle denon qu'on pourrait
appeler real madrid qui était à saint
denis je vais d'ailleurs dire ici que
des deux cette zone qui ont accueillis à
partir de 14 heures quasiment plus de
50000 personnes ont fait l'objet d'aucun
des barres de man un majeur et n'ont pas
causé de difficultés particulières il ya
évidemment la sécurisation de l'aéroport
charles de gaulle puisque l'essentiel
des espagnols sont arrivés notamment par
des avions affrétés ce qui n'a pas été
le cas le cas pardon des supporters
anglais d'études sensible puisque pour
mise à l'intérieur et préfet de police
des champs-elysées sont toujours les
lieux des rendez-vous ou des supporters
quels que soient leur équipe d'ailleurs
allié à peut-être des personnes qui
voudraient procuré une joie dans la
délinquance pour et ceux des rendez vous
sur les champs elysées malheureusement
notre pays on est souvent témoin 4 fm on
était prédisposé minuit fm dans paris
qui faisait la nuit des réserves
notamment dans les gares puisque
beaucoup de gens est notamment arrivé
par la guerre 2,2 du nord pour l'ombre
étaient présents et la gestion des flux
de voyageurs évidemment à partir de
châtelet les halles les nations qui sont
nos deux grandes gares rer qui amène de
plus de monde au stade de france sur la
seine saint denis en particulier et là
je veux répondre avec toi autre question
ne se présent la commission des lois et
les 320si effectifs de sécurité publique
à ne pas confondre avec le quasiment
6000 effectifs d'ordre public on verra
sans doute que c'est cette différence
qui est une des difficultés que nous
avons connues gevrey comparer les 326
effectifs de policiers en tenue et en
civil ou en bac qui étaient autour du
stade de france aux 164 qui étaient là
pour la finale de coupe de france c'est
à dire que nous avons doublé en
prévision de ce match qu'ils avaient
pourtant le même nombre de spectateurs a
priori le nombre d'effectifs en ordre
public et en sécurité publique dans
paris dans les fan zone qui n'existait
pas par coupe de france mais surtout
autour du stade donc pour répondre
concrètement votre question il y avait
très largement assez d'effectifs de
police pour cet événement qui était
attendue depuis effectivement plusieurs
semaines alors le déroulé précis de la
soirée se passe ainsi à partir de 18h45
il ya beaucoup de spectateurs qui
arrivent auparavant mais comme cela se
passe sans problème je n'y reviens pas
il ya eu une bagarre sur le barrage la
passerelle de les cluses et deux
tentatives d'intrusion dans un parking
vip et et dans le village l'uefa qui
étaient situées au nord entre eux à
cette zone espagnol finalement et le
stade de france très vite la police est
intervenue pour faire cesser les
troubles très individus ont été
interpellés notamment les individus qui
ont essayé d'entrer dans le parking vip
et qui se situe et on voit le petit
terrain de football là tout au nord du
stade de france à peu près ici jusqu'à
18h45 parallèlement les arrivées sont
importantes mais pour la police mais
prix maîtrisés des spectateurs dans un
contexte très difficile liée à la grève
du rer b cela a conduit énormément de
monde donc à prendre soin la ligne 13 il
ya trois stations de métro qui arrive au
stade de france ça se passera de façon
tout à fait nominal et sans aucune
difficulté y compris dans les accès au
stade de france et effectivement le r
vrd dont j'ai évoqué l'étroitesse de la
sortie
de 19h45 là est le noeud du problème
les pressions sont très importante
exercée par plusieurs milliers de
supporters et la préfecture de police
compte jusqu'à 15000 personnes dans le
goulot étroit qui le séparent de la
sortie du rer d qui prend l'année wilson
on verra tout à l'heure la l'artère pour
arriver au préfixe trash et là c'est un
point très important qui explique la
difficulté de la soirée le stade de
france a décidé depuis la coupe de
france et ailleurs depuis seulement une
semaine devant un certain nombre de
difficultés qu'il a pu connaître et pour
expérimenter notamment prévision de la
coupe du monde de rugby un nouveau
filtrage de mettre des stadiers qui
était d'ailleurs plus en grand nombre
cette fois-ci kader x 1600 stadiers pour
ce match 1300 pour la finale de coupe de
france pour le nombre de spectateurs le
fin des contrôles de près filtrage à
l'entrée bien en amont du maï du stade
de france c'est la deuxième fois que le
stade de france se faisait la première
fois c'était passé sans encombre la
coupe de france la deuxième fois donc on
contrôler les billets pour ceux qui
portaient des billets bien en amont à la
sortie il a quasiment du rer d dans
l'entrée du périmètre du stade de france
je voudrais aussi dire que ce n'est pas
les services de police qui contrôle
libye et je sais que c'est entendu mais
comme je le lis parfois des choses un
peu érodés je veux le dire ici en
revanche
les gendarmes mobiles et des crs en
l'occurrence là les gendarmes mobiles
sont à l'appui des stadiers afin de ne
pas laisser passer des gens qui
n'auraient pas de billet ou que ces
billets seraient faux d'autres que nous
sans doute la fédération française de
football pourrait vous dire que dans
l'évier effectivement ans le club de
liverpool a demandé que l'intégralité de
ces billets ont été en papier
tous les matchs qui se sont déroulés pas
la championne tic jusqu'à la finale les
billets étaient électronique la demande
de liverpool a été papier les 20000
supporters anglais qui avaient le droit
comme il est vingt mille madrilène as
des billets ont demandé des pales billet
papier le club madrilène la mise
conviendra d'en demander beaucoup moins
mais comme liverpool l'intégralité j'ai
ici je vous laisserais bien évidemment
un vrai ticket est un faux tickets le
coupon pardon est parti il ya derrière
les tickets forêt ou faux un petit carré
et les stadiers du stade de france ont
un stylo chimique qui permet de raturer
pourvoir selon la couleur est ce que ces
billets vrai ou est-ce que ce billet est
faux parce que malheureusement la
technique des faux billets très lucratif
a déjà été éprouvée si j'ose dire
notamment d'angleterre mais pas
seulement en angleterre et il s'est
trouvé que dans ce premier prêt filtrage
que nous on a appliqué que la stade de
france par bonds à appliquer partout sur
toutes les entrées du stade de france
seule l'entrée du rer d qui a mené le
plus évidemment de supporters anglais
vers les virages britannique qu'on verra
le sud on va vous allez un petit peu
trop vite peut juste avant on poser des
problèmes et d'après les équipes de la
fédération française de football et du
stade de france plus de 50 % des billets
entre 57 et 70% selon les entrées
étaient faux ça ne veut pas dire que
tous les supporters avaient des billets
faut il ya eu beaucoup de supporters qui
n'avaient également pas de billets parce
qu'ils ont essayé de s'approcher du
stade de france pour diverses raisons
qui leur appartiennent et puis dans ce
public et aussi des personnes qui te
jamais des vrais billets et c'est un bon
compte sans doute qu'une partie des gens
qui ont des faux billets pense que ce
sont des vrais ils sont très
difficilement reconnaissables vous les
verrez vous même il ya eu deux types de
fraudes que nous avons totalement
caractérise et qui fait l'objet de
l'article 40 qui a fait le préfet de
police à ma demande et l'ouverture
immédiate d'une enquête par le parquet
de bobigny le premier type de fraude
qu'on avait caractérisé ces des
personnes qui ont acheté des billets
qu'on savait à peu près fausse va venir
assez efficace parce qu'on les a achetés
à la sauvette que ce soit en angleterre
ou à paris pour 50 livres chacun et ça
permettait en tout cas avant qu'on ne
sache qui est des prêts filtrage aux
sans doute quand on était un supporteur
britannique de pouvoir passer d'accéder
valérie du stade de france puisque
ensuite après ce pré filtrage il ya le
tourniquet qui lui prévoient la lecture
qr codes de ce ticket et puis il ya ceux
qui sans doute ont acheté un deuxième
type de fraude m peut-être si je dis en
toute honnêteté avec des billets qui
seront vendus entre 800 et 1200 euros
dans des faux sites ou dans des endroits
on a vendu des billets papier en faisant
croire que c'était des vrais billets
je vous donne un exemple il ya parfois
des bas on en vend ses billets
officielle parce que ça partenariat on
connaît sans doute ça dans nos propres
commune hélas ces tickets très cher qui
ressemble vraiment exactement au premier
on verra d'ailleurs ce qui explique les
chiffres de l'uefa dès 2700 faux tickets
qu'ils ont compté eux c'est sans doute
des vrais faux billets dont les gens ont
cru très certainement encore aujourd'hui
qu'ils étaient des vrais billets mais
dont les enquêtes montrera sans
difficulté qu'ils étaient des faux donc
on a eu beaucoup de monde en r vrd trois
fois et demie de plus du fait d'une part
de la grève du rer b et du fil on le
verra aussi du nombre très important de
supporters ou de spectateurs au sud et
64 bits personnes qui accueillent
naturellement vraiment le stade de
france arrivé à ce prêt filtrage dans un
endroit déjà extrêmement étroits la
masse des personnes qui ne pouvaient pas
passer puisqu'il y avait énormément de
s'oublier constaté par les stadiers du
stade de france s'accumuler et devant
cette accumulation évidemment il ya eu
un certain nombre de débordements qui a
constaté la préfecture de police vous
avez sur le côté droit des tweets qui
enlève nos amis de nos amis ou des
constats britannique des faux billets en
vente notamment là c'est sur twitter le
les réseaux sociaux en sont pleins on
pourrait dire que côté espagnol il y
avait même nom de spectateurs aucun
problème aucun constat de faux billets
et pour ça ces familles d'espagnols
20000 anglais et à tous les autres tous
ceux qui ont acheté des billets c'est
choisir en france ou qui sont venues
elles sont supportées particulièrement à
les clubs de liverpool real madrid ont
pu rentrer sans aucun problème ni de
faux tickets ni d'ordre public ni de
près filtrage
le premier problème et on y reviendra
parce que c'est ce qui a créé évidemment
la grande confusion que l'on a connu le
premier problème a été renforcée par le
deuxième problème c'est à dire après le
prêt filtrage puisqu'on a levé ce prêt
filtrage pour des questions d'ordre
public on y reviendra ce son côté des
virages britannique les citoyens
britanniques ou supporters de l'équipe
de liverpool qui sont présentés dans les
tourniquets on a passé le qr code et là
nous avons effectivement d'après des
chiffres de l'unef et nous avons les
mêmes chiffres que l'uefa de 1889 faux
billets qui ont été scannées au tripode
c'est évidemment les machines qui
permettent de passer alors plusieurs
billets ont été dupliqués des centaines
de fois par le prestataire donc c'est
les chiffres du prestataire orange qui a
mis la connectique des portiques de
sécurité du stade de france un même
billet c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a
acheté un billet officiel a été parfois
dupliquer pour la 760 fois avec le même
bureau vous avez évidemment des numéros
là votre place dans le stade votre rang
dans le stade enfin chacun voit ce
qu'est habillé de football ou
d'événements sportifs un autre 544 fois
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens qu'on va
acheter villiers et comme de vrais
faussaires ils ont reproduit ces billets
pour les vendre eux-mêmes et évidemment
ils ont reproduit les numéros qui
existait vraiment mais au lieu qu'ils
existent eu qu'une seule fois il ya des
gens qui ont multiplié par 7 144 la
place qu'ils auraient dû savoir ce qui
fait que lorsque dans la confusion des
genres sont rentrés parfois dans le
stade sans contrôle parce qu'il y en a
eu quelques-uns quand même il ya des
témoignages d'ailleurs sur la zone the
keys ben moi j'ai même ticket que
quelqu'un est donc je m'assois voilà
c'est une autre problème qu'on a eu
effectivement je voudrais dire que tous
les documents que je présente monsieur
présent j'en ai fait une copie pour vous
et pour monsieur présent de la
commission des affaires culturelles et
évidemment je vous laisse ce soin d'en
distribuer si vous souhaitez aux
sénateurs ça nous vient directement donc
de la connectique que orange alors
revenons à notre premier problème près
filtrage puisqu'on à 15000 personnes
autour de 19h30 qui s'agglutinent des
femmes des enfants évidemment des
personnes qui peuvent être en mobilité
réduite qui sont sous le tunnel de l'a86
au sud de notre stade de france les
virages et clubs anglais sont eux dans
les portes notamment y z et à c'est à
dire au dessus des espagnols étant tout
à l'opposé est là devant le nombre très
important de personnes qui sont bloquées
et refoulé par les stadiers parce que on
considère qu'ils n'ont pas de bons
tickets le préfet de police prend la
décision de lever le pré filtrage afin
d'éviter des écrasements et des
bousculades et je pense que c'est cette
décision monsieur le président de la
commission des lois qui à éviter des
drames humains qui auraient
malheureusement tout à fait pu arriver
et qui sont arrivés malheureusement dans
l'histoire du football et de les foules
se présentant au tour des stats donc à
partir de ce moment 19h45 il n'y a plus
de pré filtrage les gendarmes mobiles
lève à la demande du préfet de police de
filtrage et des milliers de personnes en
l'occurrence 15me mais il ya plein de
gens qui sortent du r-vrd je rappelle qu
à 19h45 nous sommes encore à 1h15 du
coup d'envoi officiel se présentent sur
le match du stade de france et se
présentent aux grilles et notamment
concentré dans les virages anglais il
n'y a pas de problème dans les autres
tribunes y ait des as qui correspond au
sud du dispositif
les stadiers de contrôle plus près
filtrage il videmment non plus beaucoup
évidemment d'intérêt devant la confusion
il ce recul est désormais cette foule a
accès aux tourniquets d'accès c'est à
dire là où on a constaté par ailleurs
les 2800 faux tickets par l'adie
signalétique orange l'a évidemment
devant le monde très important et on
peut estimer les chiffres évidemment ne
sont pas fiables disais encore à cette
heure mais à 5 à 6000 le nombre de gens
qui poussent les grilles de ces deux et
trois portes et notamment des portes
d'urgence qui a 300 kg lâche et
permettent de rentrer dans le stade et
c'est normal puisque c'est la sécurité
civile le préfet de police prend une
deuxième décision qui est de rapatrier
l'ordre public les gendarmes mobiles et
qui encadraient ces prêts fait le trajet
est bien encadré
sortie du rer d qui est assez longue
quand vous regardez la carte on les
reverra si vous le souhaitez jusqu'aux
tribunes pour mettre les gendarmes de
l'autre côté des grilles pour éviter que
des grilles ne lâche et accessoirement
éviter les intrusions c'est sans doute
ce qui évoquera les questions de
délinquance puisque sur ce mail de
cheminement entre la sortie du rer d et
le stade de france il n'y aura plus ou
beaucoup moins de forces de police
puisqu'ils sont tous rapatriés en
urgence devant le mouvement de foule
dans le stade pour soutenir si j'ose
dire les grilles et pour éviter les
intrusions et donc soit à l'écrasement
contre les grilles soit l'envahissement
du terrain ce qui aurait évidemment
empêché le match de se dérouler
une grande partie donc des forces été
repositionné je les dis et la laiterie
potes c'est à dire les tourniquets il
faut bien voir ce que ça veut dire sur
trois portes il y avait à peu près vingt
mille supporters anglais même de 1800
faux tickets c'est quand même plus de
10% des 20000 et donc quand vous êtes on
a vu tous des images parfois de gens
très connus dont le ticket semblait ne
pas marcher et qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont
fait sont passés en dessous ils sont
passés au dessus est évidemment au bout
d'un moment plus personne n'a mis son
ticket et a décidé de passer si je dire
comme dans un métro où tout le monde
frauderait de l'autre côté les effectifs
alors procèdent à des opérations de
maintien entre le mail donc c'est à dire
en dehors du stade de france pourrait
lancer les milliers d'individus et de
certains os il vous avez tout à fait
raison et on peut considérer qu'en
d'ordre public à partir de la fin de la
première mi temps il n'y a plus de
difficulté ou 13 accessoires sur le
stade sur le stade de france
l'évacuation a lors du match ce fait je
parle de la fin de seconde mi-temps sans
sans difficulté alors même que liverpool
a perdu comme chacun l'a vu pas de
bagarre pas d'envahissement de terrain
et tout le monde repart si j'ose dire
prendre ces transports avec de nouvelles
difficultés délinquance sur le mile
puisque l'ordre public n'est plus
rétabli entre les rer d et le stade de
france et je rappelle que les deux
femmes zone notamment celle qui comporte
quasiment quarante mille supporters
cours de vincennes se fait dans des
conditions nominale à une exception près
de la nation ou le tenancier d'un
restaurant demande l'ordre public
après avoir eu son restaurant des restes
épars des supporters sans doute deviné
alors le point principal monsieur le
président puisque c'est votre question
c'est comment on arrive à 30 milles ou
quarante mille personnes supplémentaires
des 75000 personnes du stade de france
je comprends bien que ce chiffre est
important on n'a jamais dit si vous me
le permettez avec la ministre des sports
que c'était 35 mille faux billets nous
avons toujours dit que c'était 30000 à
40000 personnes soit non porteurs de
billets soit ayant des faux billets qui
sera ajouté aux 75 une personne qui eux
avaient un vrai billet alors nous avons
au moins de possibilités de source pour
ceux qui ne croient pas la préfecture de
police la première peut-être c'est celle
de la fédération française de football
qui elle même communiqué officiellement
vous avez dû voir cela il 75000 et non
pas 80 mille billets édités par la
fédération c'est à dire par
l'organisateur l'uefa ss
175 les personnes qui auraient dû se
rendre au stade de france
malheureusement nous avons constaté
cent dix mille personnes dans le stade
de france et autour du stade de france
ayant emprunté les transports ça se
décompose comme suit 79 1200 personnes
c'est à dire le plus déjà de nombreux
cas des billets qui ont pris les
transports en commun on a lignes de rer
vous le verrez par lignes de rer les
détails des personnes qui ont été
comptés on ne remercie la ratp la sncf
21000 bus de très facile à savoir
puisque l'intégralité des supporters
espagnols organisé par leurs clubs sont
arrivés par des bus c'est le cas
seulement de 1/3 des supporters anglais
c'est un signe un de nos problèmes et
puis évidemment tous ceux qui sont
arrivés en véhicules particuliers
six mille textes y est chauffeur privé
après avoir contacté la fédération a
contacté des sociétés de taxis et les
sociétés privées de chauffeurs privés
qui vont évidemment la géo localisation
de leurs courses et 4100 personnes avec
un véhicule particulier des parkings en
font foi
ce qui veut dire vous allez le tableau
récapitulatif
que selon les chiffres donnés non pas
par nous mais par la ratp ou la sncf
attendait pour venir allez-y nous avons
exactement les mêmes chiffres à quelques
centaines
allez moins de 5000 près c'est tout à
fait possible je rappelle que je
regrette personnellement que nous
n'ayons pas pu utiliser des drones pour
pouvoir mettre la gestion de la foule
plus de l'image sur nos sujets mais nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler dans
d'autres circonstances la ligne 13 la
ratp faisait naître 27000 personnes qui
sont venues au stade de france le r vrd
nord 37000 on voit bien la sur
représentation du rer d qui d'habitude
n'est pas celui qui accueillent de plus
de personnes puisque celui laquelle plus
de personnes c'est le rer b qui la
relève de la sncf je veux dire ici à
ceux qui pensent qu'il ya un problème de
chiffres entre nous que leur herbe et
gare du nord direct stade de france est
gérée par la sncf et que les chiffres
ratp rer b qui fait des stations si
j'ose dire normal et l'a gérée par la
ratp ce qui fait la différence et 6500
que l'on voit parfois entre les deux
comptages et les 10500 donc gérée par la
ratp en rire l'herbe est ce qui nous
fait donc un sou total déjà de 80000
personnes qui se rendent paraître
transport public au stade de france
alors que le stade là que 75 mille
billets nous y rajoute ont bien
évidemment les taxis des taxis g7 les
vais tester de toute sorte les gens qui
sont arrivés en car les gens qui sont
arrivés en bus des gens qui sont arrivés
en provenance de leurs propres véhicules
dans les parkings et donc nous
attendions tous un chiffrage qui
entre-temps 9000 et 117 mille personnes
c'est-à-dire plus beaucoup plus de 30000
personnes 34800 sur la fourchette basse
quarante deux mille huit cents soit
fourchette haute ces personnes soient
sont rentrés dans le stade de façon
numéraire à quelques centaines près sans
doute soit sont restées aux abords
immédiats du stade de france soit sont
allé un peu plus loin les abords
immédiats de france sous l'effet de
l'ordre public mais aussi sous l'effet
parfois des prêts filtrage puisque le
pré filtrage n'a pas fonctionné que dans
les portes sud de liverpool pour les
raisons que j'ai évoquées et partout
ailleurs les gens n'ont pas pu accéder
au parvis du stade de france en ce
qu'ils avaient soit des faux billets
soient pas de billet du tout et puis un
deuxième phénomène qui sans doute a fait
louer une partie des supporteurs c'est
que pour tous ceux qui sont allés au
stade de france la 4g fonctionne mal et
quand on rentre pas dans un stade et
qu'on va regarder un match eh ben on
essaye de trouver quand on est
supporters par ailleurs la captation de
son téléphone et donc ça a sans doute
encouragé on le reverra des gens à
partir très rapidement aussi quand ils
n'ont pas pu rentrer dans le stade alors
comment on peut dire que parce que
beaucoup jeudi les critiques et 10 des
accords très bien imaginons qu'il
transmet une personne de plus mais ils
sont passés où ses trente cinq mille
personnes et bien la sncf a elle-même
documenté on vous a également fourni la
note qu'elle nous a fourni qu'à 22h52
c'est à dire au lendemain de la première
mi temps de très nombreux supporters ont
commencé à reprendre les métros et en
l'occurrence ici le rer d et donc
comment ça s'est passé il ya eu un
décalage une demi heure du coup d'envoi
on est passé dès 21h à 21h30 21h30 22h15
première mi temps 22h15 22h30 mi temps
22h30 et 23h15 fin du match et au moment
où la ratp sncf pour répondre à une
vocation de l'anticipation attend la fin
du match parce qu'on avait évidemment
décalé avec eux les lignes de rer après
le décalage du du coup de sifflet final
ce qui objectivement est une grande
prouesse de la part de la ratp sncf de
rappeler leurs conducteurs et et leurs
trames le rame de métro dans des
contextes 10 paires urgence eh bien ils
ont même dû anticiper cela puisque dès
22h45 en 252 nous dit la sncf mais des
images de vidéo protection que je ne
peux pas vous fournir pour des raisons
de protection des libertés mais qu' ils
sont à votre disposition je suis sûre
s'ils voulaient demander à qui de droit
démontre que les quais du rer d
notamment de la plaine stade de france
ont plein plein de beaucoup de maillots
rouges et malheureusement la sncf doit
refaire venir très rapidement des trains
et des 22 ans 152e les trains repartent
à paris dans des conditions évidemment
qui n'ont rien à voir avec un match en
mal tout le monde attend en général la
fin d'un match lorsque ce match n'est
pas infinie alors je me suis permis ça
répondre à votre question sur notamment
la note de l'adn nhc un comparatif avec
la finale de coupe de france que nous
avions organisée si j'ose dire quelques
jours auparavant ce match de coupe de
france était a priori d'après la drh
plus dangereux que le match de
championnat se dit et chacun sait que
certains clubs de supporters des deux
clubs de football qui se sont opposés je
n'aurais pas faire d' insulte ici
particulière aux sénateurs élus de céder
retenant poser des problèmes de
supportérisme comme on dit très
important et c'était déjà un match de
football que nous avions
particulièrement mis autour de l'ordre
public et où s'est déroulée très peu
d'incidents il ya eu plus de spectateurs
plus de billets vendus pour la finale de
coupe de france que pour la chanteuse
dit il y a eu à chacun le voit source
sur ce graphique il ya eu 160 2 1
policiers engagés de sécurité publique
pour la coupe de france 326 donc je les
dis pour la chanteuse dit qu il y avait
800 dix policiers d'ordre public pour la
coupe de france en habit 300 de plus
quasiment là je parle bien de cela ni du
stade je parle pas du reste de paris
mille cent soixante dix pour leur public
ils 0 agression de policiers ou de
gendarmes y en a eu dix pendant la
championne si il ya eu zéro sadi agressé
pendant la coupe de france il y en a eu
dix dont un gravement lors de ce match
de championnat et notamment ce qu'il
fallait le pré filtrage celui du à
regarder avant que nous levions le sujet
il ya eu trois plaintes déposées pour le
stade de france il y en a eu 35 on y
reviendra pour le stage de champions
league et il ya eu 28 interpellations
lors de la finale de coupe de france et
à saint denis il ya une trentaine
d'interpellations par ailleurs à paris
notamment pour des ivresses sur la voie
publique 80 une interpellation au stade
de france dont 29 dans le stade de
france qui prévoyait les intrusions pour
répondre à votre question la moitié des
personnes qui ont été interpellées de
son qui ont sauté des grilles étaient
des citoyens britanniques
et sur les excuser moi pardon elle
détaille et sur les 50 2 en dehors du
stade qui ont été interpellés c'est
effectivement les 13 qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure sur le parking des ip et puis
les autres qui ont se sont livrés à des
rapides ou à des agressions en effet
donc c'est un montant important
d'interpellations par la sécurité
publique j'ai noté pour répondre à votre
question que sur les 80 une
interpellation que nous avons commises
25 ont été commis par des étrangers hors
de l'union européenne pour répondre
directement à la question je regrette
d'ailleurs qu'on est à détailler les
nationalités des personnes interpellées
mais je suis bien obligé de répondre à
quelques faits que news qui circulent
malheureusement sur paris la
seine-saint-denis tous confondus y
compris les fans zone et 805
interpellations qui ont conduit à 73
garde à vue je veux rappeler ici que les
milieux intérieurs ne décident pas des
poursuites judiciaires des personnes que
nous interpellons donc j'entends qu'il
ya des questions sur la suite judiciaire
je suis parfois celui qui peut déplorer
un certain nombre de non poursuite
judiciaire mais je suis bien dans mon
rôle en vous parlant que des
interpellations de la police nationale
gendarmerie
alors qu'est ce que nous aurions d'abord
qu'est ce que nous pouvons faire des
immédiatement pour essayer de comprendre
encore mieux ce qui s'est passé
notamment vis-à-vis des personnes qui
ont été floués parce qu'il y en a eu
d'aidé floués et notamment des personnes
qui ont pu parce qu'ils sont citoyens
britanniques aux madrilènes pas déposé
plainte et je ne veux pas sous-estimer
le fait que venant d'angleterre ou
venant d'espagne on n'a pas forcément le
même réflexe quand on vient de nantes au
canton vient de nice pour un match de
football donc je vais proposer qu'à
partir de lundi les citoyens espagnols
et des citoyens britanniques puissent
déposer plainte dans leur pays et je
vais dépêché des policiers français à
madrid et en angleterre je l'espère à
liverpool mais si ce n'est à l ombre
évidemment une plateforme informatique
en langue espagnole et anglaise et puis
des lettres plaintes ont déjà rédigé
dans les langues de ces deux pays avec
des policiers français pour qu'on puisse
bien voir quelles sont les suites
judiciaires répondre évidemment à
chacune des plaintes qui serait déposée
avec les preuves notamment les preuves
vidéos qu'ils auraient pu faire et bien
évidemment faire des poursuites
systématiques de ces personnes et que
nous ayons et on vous communiquera
monsieur président de la commission des
lois les résultats puisqu'elle sans
doute une partie des plaintes qui n'ont
pas été déposée parce que ses citoyens
repartait de soi même ou le lendemain
dans leur pays je veux aussi dire que le
parquet de bobigny s'est saisie pour les
faits commis de faux billets
de manière massive industriel je
maintiens le mot d'ailleurs j'ai
constaté que la femme faisait elle même
une enquête sur ce sujet je peux dire
qu'il est tout à fait loisirs évidemment
pour d'autres pays de pouvoir faire les
enquêtes ci dessous est sûre c'est fait
je n'ai pas vu à ma connaissance
d'ouverture de ce point mais je pense
que nous serions tout à fait au rendez
vous et c'est la justice de le dire de
cette coopération et puis troisièmement
je pense que c'est très important on
doit tirer des conclusions pour la suite
la ministre des sports il reviendra je
reste simplement terminé sur nombreux
public qu'avons nous mal fait nous avons
sans doute sous-estimé le nombre de
policiers en tout cas l'action de la
police de sécurité publique à partir du
moment ce qui était difficilement
prévisible mais être ministre et être
responsable c'est sans doute encore plus
prévoir que l'ordre public dégénérait et
qu'on aurait levé les barrages tendre
public ce qui faisait qu'une partie de
l'espace entre les regarder et le stade
de france ont été livrés avec peu de
policiers à sa tombe de personnes qui
profitant évidemment de la confusion se
sont livrés à des violences et donc je
crois qu'il faut tirer conclusion de
cela après avoir beaucoup plus de
policiers de sécurité publique parce que
chacun voit qu'un policier d'ordre
public casqués avec son équipement dont
le travail est de faire un gros public
n'est pas là pour intervenir en
délinquance à quelques centaines de
mètres y en a qui l'ont fait je sans
merci mais ce n'est pas leur travail et
c'est donc pas non plus la
réglementation qui est utilisée dès
vendredi pour le stade pour france
danemark même si ce match à un danger
plus réduit il aurait je le dire
d'ailleurs que l'athée quasi intégralité
des billets sont électroniques à
quelques centaines prêt mais la ministre
y reviendra nous en tirerons toutes les
conséquences et évidemment pour les
matches et pour un certain nombre de
compétitions plus tard ça veut dire
aussi qu'il faut faire un effort
extrêmement important pour la ville de
saint denis et pour la préfecture de
police de caméras vidéo protection sur
l'ensemble de l'année r-vrd stade de
france puisque c'est surtout le rer b la
ligne 13 qui sont vidéosurveillées dont
acte j'y mettrai les moyens dès le mois
prochain pour équiper l'ensemble cet axe
et troisièmement ça veut effectivement
aussi dire que nous devons anticiper ce
qui manifestement s'est passé ici au
stade de france en cas d'afflux très
important et non prévus on peut imaginer
attentat on peut imaginer le pas non
plus imaginer rassemblement un incendie
bref ce rassemblement sont tout à fait
possibles sans doute pas autant de 30
lits mais tout à fait possible un
dispositif d'urgence particulier pour
lutter contre l'insécurité le public le
deuxième sujet c'est évidemment l'ordre
public moi je veux dire ici que les
décisions qui ont été prises ont permis
de sauver des vies il ya eu des gestes
inappropriés disproportionnée va certain
nombre de la part de deux policiers ou
de gendarmes mobiles
qui ont été documentés je veux dire
qu'il ya deux saisines igpn en tout cas
de signalement j'ai évidemment donné
instruction et j'ai peine de les étudier
je veux dire que lorsque les madrilènes
et les anglais pourront déposer plainte
ippon aussi faire des saisies gpn on
leur expliquera bien évidemment et j'ai
vu personnellement de fait ou
manifestement l'ordre public et
l'utilisation du gaz lacrymogène était
contraire aux règles d'emploi et j'ai
demandé des sanctions aux préfets de
police pour ces deux responsables des
forces de l'ordre je veux cependant dire
et remettre dans le contexte que lorsque
des milliers et dans un certains cas
plus d'une dizaine de milliers de
personnes se pressent
et malgré le fait que dans cette foule
il ya parfaitement des gens honnêtes et
des gens qui venaient au stade si j'ose
dire en bon père en bonne mère de
famille pour faire reculer une foule qui
va connaître un écrasement les policiers
et les gendarmes sans doute dans
l'urgence et sous leurs données à la
hiérarchie pour utiliser des moyens de
dispersion est ce que ces moyens de
dispersion sont adéquats pour un
événement comme celui-ci manifestement
l'expérience mérite d'être très
largement revu et j'ai donc demandé dès
maintenant je sais le préfet cadot y
travaillent par ailleurs de voir dans le
cadre des événements sportifs dans un
événement exceptionnel comme celui ci
qui n'a jamais eu lieu dans cette
proportion en france on puisse voir
évidemment des règles d'emploi
différents je veux dire que ceres le
jardin mobile n'avait pas d'autre moyen
de faire disperser la foule mais il s'en
doute de la botte de la faute de
l'administration qu'ils en donnent pas
les moyens techniques de le faire sinon
c'était et finalement des grenades anti
rassemblement où dell bd ce qui
évidemment n'était pas du tout
proportionnée donc le gaz lacrymogène a
permis de sauver un certain nombre de
personnes de l'écrasement il a aussi
posé causer de grands dégâts notamment
sur des enfants j'ai quand même vu comme
voulait des images voudrais m'en excuser
très sincèrement de cette utilisation
disproportionnée et des sanctions
surpris je voulais communiquerait si
vous souhaitez monsieur le président de
la commission des lois voilà ce que je
vais vous dire en quelques mois j'étais
un peu long mais il me semblait
nécessaire je tiens à votre disposition
l'ensemble des documents et je suis prêt
évidemment à répondre à toute question
je veux dire que l'anneau des lainages
que vous aurez dans votre dossier ne
prévoit pas des milliers de faux billets
le mieux c'est puisque tous les
documents sont son public mais jamais
retranscrit intégralement et prévoit
deux fautes possible cette note de la
dette et lâche la première c'est que des
personnes tenteront de pénétrer paru
dans l'enceinte sportive en utilisant
par exemple des 10 ni forme de stewart
du personnel l'uefa du personnel médical
des agents nettoyage se fait demain
prévu par la dh n'est pas arrivé fort
heureusement on s'était préparé à cela
et deuxièmement de plus et comme cela
peut être constaté lors des pré sence
finale jouée par le club de liverpool je
rappelle ici que n'a vu aucun problème
avec les supporters madrilènes et aucun
problème avec les autres supporters
plusieurs centaines de supporters
anglais pas plusieurs milliers tenteront
de pénétrer dans le stade en forçant les
tourniquets et différentes portes
d'accès et donc nous avons prévu un port
cela la fan zone et deux pour cela la le
la surnomme le surnombre de policiers
comme je voulais évoquer d'ordre public
mais effectivement qui n'étaient pas
prévus pour des dizaines de milliers
je veux aussi dire qu'il ya eu
dysfonctionnement puisque je dois la
vérité évidemment à allah non pas la
commission met à votre audition que
cette ode à l'ena je tape a été
transmise à la préfecture de police
contrairement aux autres matches je m'en
suis inquiété personnellement je
multiplie les réunions pour savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé c'est
effectuera dysfonctionnement du
ministère je vais en tirer les
conclusions je prends évidemment cette
faute pour noël n'aurait pas changé à
mon avis grand chose puisque par
définition des craintes évoquées n'ont
pas été
soumis puisqu'il n'y avait pas des
milliers des personnes prévues mais il
est évident que le préfet de police qui
est garant de l'ordre public à paris et
en petite couronne aurait dû connaître
cette note
merci monsieur le ministre pour cette
mise au point indique d'ores et déjà nos
collègues que vingt et une personnes
intéressées nateur sénatrice se sont
fait connaître pour poser une question
donc mais le feront après que ban lamy
se soit exprimé je vous en prie valable
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des lois soit
noël buffet monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires culturelles de
l'éducation laurent lafon mesdames et
messieurs et sénatrices et les sénateurs
je suis évidemment honoré d'être devant
vous aujourd'hui pour cette audition
pour la première fois devant le
parlement
ma qualité de ministre des sports et des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques mais
j'aurais bien entendu aimé que cela
puisse se produire dans des
circonstances plus positive
ma démarche
notre démarche avec le ministre de
l'intérieur c'était évidemment une
démarche de transparence la plus
complète possible devant vous je
répondrai donc le plus précisément aux
questions que vous jugerez utile de me
poser à la suite de cet exposé
je voudrais peut-être dans ce propos
liminaire commencé par exprimer nos
regrets pour les personnes dont la
soirée a été gâchée samedi soir et pour
ses 2700 supporteurs de liverpool qui
alors qu'ils avaient validement acheter
leurs tickets ont été privés de ce beau
match
je voulais dit je m'inscris devant vous
dans une démarche avec le ministre de
l'intérieur de totale transparence
mais aussi de responsabilité
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès lundi
matin à 11 heures j'ai vraiment souhaité
réunir l'ensemble des parties prenantes
pour essayer de travailler
à l'analyse des incidents établir les
responsabilités de chacun et puis tirer
les enseignements qui s'imposent
l'uefa en tant qu'organisateur de cette
compétition
la fédération française de football qui
avait certains pans de responsabilité en
délégation de l'uefa dont je rappelle
qu'il maîtrisait l'organisation de cet
événement les gestionnaires de
l'enceinte le consortium stade de france
et puis du côté de l'état la préfecture
de police la préfecture de
seine-saint-denis la dnlh bon nous avons
parlé et puis la mairie de saint denis
en tant que représentant de la
collectivité haute du mac
je voudrais vous dire
finalement peut-être les trois
principaux éléments que je retiens de
cette réunion de retour d'expérience d'
analyse
le premier point c'est d'abord la
convergence de vues et d'interprétation
sur ce qui s'est passé
certes nous avions tous des points
d'observation différents
complémentaires mais on s'est vraiment
assuré pendant ces deux heures de
travail intense que rien était
incohérent et j'y reviendrai le deuxième
élément que je retiens c'est qu'il y a
comme souvent dans pareil à faire une
forme de conjonction de circonstances de
fait j'ai envie de reprendre les mots du
stade de france quelque chose qui a
entraîné un processus dynamique est
exponentielle chaque pas franchi
amplifiant les difficultés rencontrées
de manière croissante
puis le troisième élément que je retiens
c'est quand même cette cause racines de
cette proportion extrêmement élevé de
faux billets
proportion peut-être inédite et
difficilement anticipable je voudrais à
cet égard et avant d'y revenir un petit
peu plus longuement relance youn et deux
points qui dans l'exposé du ministre de
l'intérieur me semble très important
d'abord dans cette note que moi non plus
je n'avais pas eu en amont le ministre
de l'intérieur m'a partagée de la dnlh
il est bien dit qu environ 50000 super
tôt supporteurs anglais seraient
présents dans la capitale sans être
détenteurs de billets et ensuite il est
précisé finalement trois formes de
difficultés à adresser la première des
écrits certains d'entre eux seront en
possession de faux billets est en train
d utiliser pour accéder au stade
d'autres tenteront de pénétrer par ruse
dans l'enceinte sportive en utilisant
par exemple des uniformes de stewart le
personnel de l'uefa de personnels
médicaux ou d'agents de nettoyage
notons que ce deuxième volet nous
n'avons pas constaté et puis en
troisième la dnlh identifier le risque
que plusieurs centaines de supporters
anglais tentent de pénétrer dans le
stade en forçant les tourniquets et les
différentes portes d'accès voyez bien
que dans ces termes
la proportion très forte de faux billets
n'étaient pas qualifiés parmi ces 50
milles nous n'étions pas alerté sur le
fait que le volume de ces faux billets
pourraient être aussi élevé un autre
élément que je voudrais mentionner c'est
le fait que le ministre de l'intérieur
l'a rappelé organisé en trois mois mais
aussi ne connaître que le 4 mai
l'identité des finalistes
dont le club de liverpool avec la
spécificité très forte de ses supporters
de leurs techniques et c'est donc le
temps d'adaptation à leur technique à
leur façon de faire peut-être aux
risques spécifiques qu'il présente ses
supporters ce temps nous a été
malheureusement très content et alors le
ministre de l'intérieur a été
formidablement exhaustif dans son dans
son exposé
je ne vais donc pas du tout revenir sur
tous ces éléments il y en a juste un sur
lequel vous me permettrez de revenir
parce que il est pour moi absolument
capital dans tout ce que j'entends ces
dernières heures ces derniers jours
sur cette affaire j'ai le sentiment
qu'il ya la perception d'une incohérence
entre ces 30 à 40000 supporters sans
billet ou avec de faux billets et les
2800 faux billets scanner aux ultimes
portes de contrôle rapporté par l'uefa
alors
on a vraiment essayé de décortiquer au
mieux de l'information qui est à date en
notre possession de décortiquer cette
arithmétique de comprendre alors les
deux enquêtes celle auprès du parquet de
bobigny celle approfondie de l'uefa sur
la billetterie nous donnerons évidemment
des éléments un petit peu plus précis
mais je voudrais partager ce qui pour
moi n'est pas une incohérence mais au
contraire une cohérence
d'abord c'est le premier point j'aurais
sept points dans ce dans ce passage le
premier point le ministre de l'intérieur
l'a rappelé nos 35 me no 30 à 40 milles
depuis exactement nous avons bien dit
que c'était soit des personnes sans
billets soient des personnes avec de
faux billets la proportion de l'un et de
l'autre n'étant pas clair étant
difficile à établir peut-être que les
enquêtes nous donneront un petit peu de
peu plus de visibilité sur ça elles
seront probablement difficile à établir
jusqu'au bout
ce qu'on sait c'est que ces supporters
sans billet cette première des deux
masses ils ont été tenus largement à
l'écart de la première zone de filtrage
et le ministre de l'intérieur l'a
rappelé les données de trafic dans les
transports en commun montre bien qu'il
ya eu un volume retour très très fort
avant même la fin du match de ses
supporters
donc ayant en tête que ce premier
ensemble de 100 billets étaient
vraisemblablement important avec ce flux
est ce premier ce premier élément de
deux filtres
le deuxième point c'est que c' est la
première zone de filtrage elle a rempli
son objectif de repousser un certain
nombre de détenteurs cette fois de faux
billets grâce au stylo chimiques qui ont
été évoqués tout à l'heure et là
l'ensemble des témoignages que nous
avons reçues sont concordants des agents
de sécurité et qui remonte une
proportion entre 55 et 70 % de faux
billets à sept premières zones de
filtrage l'ag vous rapporter une
anecdote qui m'a été comptés c'est qu'au
début l'uefa ne croyait pas à ces
statistiques alerté par les stadiers qui
étaient eux mêmes surpris de cette
proportion de faux billets se sont
demandé si ce n'était pas les stylos
chimiques qui était défectueux ils sont
venus en rapporter aux stadiers
le troisième élément qu'il faut bien
avoir en tête c'est que
c'est
une zone de premier filtrage uniquement
aux portes x y et z qui a été relâché
ce qui signifie que aux autres portes
cela a continué d'agir comme un barrage
comme un filtrage est d'ailleurs des
données qui ont été partagées par la
fédération française de football montre
qu'il y a même 33 % de ces faux billets
détectés qui relèvent d'autres portes
que x y et z
ceci nous montre bien que cette première
zone de filtrage elle a continué à
fonctionner tout au long de la période
de contrôle sur une partie significative
et rappelons nous la main courante
l'établi la zone de filtrage x y et z
elle n'a été relâché que de 19 heures 39
à 19h54 avons ensuite d'être rétabli
jusqu'à ce que vers 21h des stadiers qui
progressivement leur poste
le quatrième point c'est que quand on
passe sept premières zones de filtrage
il le fait que du coup les forces de
sécurité étaient positionnés côté x y et
z sur le parvis et bien elles ont plus à
leur tour écarté un certain nombre
d'individus qui d'évidence ne détenait
pas de titre valide pour accéder dans
l'enceinte du stade
le cinquième point c'est que lorsque
vous arrivez devant les tripodes les
agents de sécurité sont à nouveau un
barriérage où ils vérifient deux
nouveaux les billets de manière visuelle
ce qui leur permet d'écarter les fraudes
les plus évidentes et il vérifie
l'exactitude de la porte d'entrée
c'est donc total ces cinq étapes quand
on arrive à l'entonnoir de ces fameux
tripode où les
2800 environ bibi est scanné irréguliers
ont été repérés qui est le sixième point
et puis nous avons un 7e et dernier
point puisque le stade de france établi
que malgré six 6 étapes progressives il
y avait quelques centaines de
spectateurs sans billet ou son billet
valide qui avaient réussi à pénétrer
dans l'enceinte du stade
tout ceci pour vous montrer que cette
dispersion des flux ces étapes
successives de l'entonnoir
établissent en réalité une cohérence
forte entre les 30 à 40000 que nous
évoquons au début et ce chiffre donné au
tripode par les données de contrôle
d'orange à l'uefa
me semblait vraiment utile de revenir là
dessus parce que je crois que c'est un
élément qui fait peur de la confiance
dans l'analyse que nous vous restitue en
effet alors même je le rappelle qu'il y
à cette très grande convergence dynamise
de vue et d'interprétation entre
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
alors je lui ai dit tout à l'heure moi
je m'inscris dans une démarche de
responsabilité tourner vers vers
l'avenir je voudrais donc revenir sur
les quatre décisions majeures que nous
avons décidé de prendre à l'issue de
cette réunion que j'ai animé hier matin
la première c'est que nous nous sommes
dit que la première chose que nous
devions faire était de réclamer une
indemnisation une compensation pour les
2700 supporters de liverpool qui n'ont
pas pu alors même qu'ils avaient un
billet valide assister à ce match et
nous avons demandé à l'uefa de pouvoir
les compenser rapidement de manière
individualisée
le deuxième élément c'est que nous avons
demandé à l'uefa et on se satisfait que
dès lundi soir elle est annoncé qu'elle
le ferait une enquête très approfondie
sur l'ensemble des failles constatées et
notamment sur ce point très sensible de
la billetterie ou notre enjeu est de
comprendre comment cette fraude a pu
être possible dans de tels volumes avec
quelle mécanique et quelles complicités
le troisième élément c'est j'ai demandé
au préfet cadot qui est le délégué
interministériel à la gestion des
événements sportifs de rassembler de la
manière la plus exhaustive possible
l'ensemble des analyses partagées par
toutes les parties prenantes dans un
rapport qui sera public et qui vous sera
transmis messieurs les présidents
la quatrième décision c'est avec gérald
darmanin nous avons convenu de notre
volonté commune de renforcer ce pilotage
des grands événements en particulier
pour les rencontres à risque
les échanges des derniers jours
permettent déjà de comprendre que nous
allons devoir nous améliorer sur au
moins cinq dimensions
la première c'est la gestion des flux
d'abord au sortir des transports publics
des transports publics
peut-être à fortiori dans des situations
de grève un peu compliqué à anticiper à
calibrer avec une capacité
renouvelée de gérer des plans de secours
des itinéraires de délestage d'avoir des
scénarios de repli bien coordonné entre
l'ensemble des acteurs je suis ces
petits bouts d'être activé avec de
l'agilité
je précise à cet égard que sur cette
gestion des flux
nous devrons améliorer des dispositifs
au stade de france de barriérage qui
devront être mieux adapté à la pression
des spectateurs nous devrons travailler
sur l'optimisation de la gestion de
cette zone de premier filtrage avec des
aménagements matériels les moyens
humains bien recalibré une juste
répartition des responsabilités entre
les agents de sécurité privés et les
forces de sécurité et la volonté de bien
optimisé le positionnement de chacun
depuis la gestion du dernier kilomètre
nous amènera probablement aussi à faire
des choix politiques et stratégiques
peut-être de piétonnisation de certaines
voies d'accès pour écarter les risques
qui ont été remarqués samedi soir de
croisement de flux antagonistes entre
dévié ton des piétons et des véhicules
créant une dangerosité particulière
le deuxième enjeu sur laquelle nous
devons nous améliorer c'est la
communication la signalétique avec une
information bien meilleure à donner
notamment aux voyageurs et tout
particulièrement aux supporteurs dans
les transports en commun tant parisiens
aux abords du stade le troisième enjeu
si celui de la sécurité en
s'interrogeant évidemment sur les
comptes les conséquences concrètes pour
les forces de l'ordre du contrôle d'un
dispositif parfois très vaste avec de
vastes plans de circulation dans des
circonstances parfois à risque et avec
cet enjeu majeur de la qualité de la
coordination entre nos forces de
sécurité intérieure et les agents de
sécurité privés mais aussi j'insiste là
dessus avec une attention particulière
précisément sur cette filière des agents
de sécurité privés dont nous savons que
ce sont des métiers en tension qui exige
une bonne qualité de de formation et qui
seront cruciaux pour la gestion de nos
prochains grands événements
le quatrième en jeu au regard des faits
de délinquance constatés nous savons que
nous devrons veiller à une meilleure
intégration à une meilleure anticipation
des dispositifs de lutte contre la
délinquance au sein des services d'ordre
pour assurer et garantir la sécurisation
générale de nos grands événements et
puis le cinquième et dernier en jeu
c'est celui de la billetterie avec la
nécessité d'abord d'une utilisation plus
systématique de la billetterie
électronique tout en l'accompagnant des
travaux nécessaires sur la blogo chain
qui permettront de fiabiliser l'ensemble
mais aussi une attention particulière
aux risques de cyber sécurité
le deuxième point sur ce registre de la
billetterie c'est d'améliorer nos
techniques de prévention de la fraude on
le voit c'est un phénomène qui n'est pas
spécifique à ce qu'a connu la france
samedi soir et en la matière peut être
qu'une coopération européenne
internationale dans le monde du football
et peut-être un petit peu au-delà sera
nécessaire en matière de renseignement
je vous partage ses pistes de travail
ses premiers enseignements sur lequel le
préfet cadot dans son rapport reviendra
mais je voudrais peut-être
vous livrer encore deux ou trois
messages le premier d'entre eux c'est
qu'il faut jamais oublier que notre pays
y compris dans le passé récent à cette
longue tradition fructueuse de réception
des grands événements je voudrais leur
rappeler la ryder cup en 2018 avait
réuni 270 mille spectateurs de 90
nationalités différentes
championnats de hand masculin en 2010 7
540 mille personnes celui féminin le
championnat d'europe de hand tenus sur
notre sol sans difficulté la coupe du
monde féminine de 2010 9,1 me 1,2
million le spectateur roland garros en
ce moment avec ses quarante mille
spectateurs quotidiens
au delà de ce savoir-faire encore
confirmé le ministre de l'intérieur l'a
dit avec la finale de la coupe de france
il ya une qualité de gouvernance et de
mobilisation que je veux souligner avec
la délégation interministérielle aux
grands événements sportifs l'adie job
pour les jeux olympiques le rôle de
l'instance de coordination nationale
pour la sécurité des jeux et de la coupe
du monde 2023 avec le préfet zied khoury
et l'ensemble de ces personnes
extraordinairement mobilisés pour
travailler sur toutes les activités de
sécurité et de sûreté qui concourront à
la bonne organisation nos événements en
conclusion
mesdames messieurs
vous l'avez compris on ira au bout de
toutes les conclusions sur ces incidents
au bout de toutes les leçons qui nous
appartient en responsabilité d'en tirer
je considère moi peut-être c'est la
sportive qui parlent que ces événements
dont on veut qu'ils ne se reproduisent
jamais nous pousserons a progressé à
nous remettre en question la hausse est
nécessaire et à réunir toutes les
conditions de façon irréprochable pour
faire de nos grands événements des
succès sportifs mais aussi les fêtes
populaires que les français sont en
droit d'attendre
mes pensées vont aussi aux britanniques
je veux leur redire tous mes regrets
pour ceux d'entre eux privés de ce match
mais aussi les appeler à une certaine
compréhension des difficultés que nous
avons rencontrées puisque lorsqu'on
regarde en détail le rapport fait par la
baronne whiskeys et sur les événements
de la finale de l'euro en juillet 21
entre l'italie
et l'angleterre
les choses ont été très difficiles
également elle parle d'un échec
collectif à anticiper les risques de 17
brèche dans le dispositif de sécurité
d'une période de confusion allant d'une
heure trente avant le coup d'envoi
jusqu'aux tirs au but de concentration
de foule de chute de barrières elle
évoque des attaques contre les policiers
et les stewards qui ont été d'une
violence sans précédent selon les
organisateurs souvenons de de tout ça
alors j'ai bien entendu été pour ma part
sensible à l'appel du club de liverpool
moi je veux leur dire que tout ce que
nous regrettons dans ce trafic dont on a
besoin d'eux on a besoin absolument de
comprendre dans cette désorganisation
peut-être qui a tranché avec
l'encadrement avec lequel le real madrid
a accompagné ses supporters tout ça ne
retire évidemment rien au fait que ce
club de liverpool est un grand club avec
un grand coach et de grands joueurs
enfin
soyez vraiment persuadé de notre
mobilisation la plus complète la plus
totale pour faire du match france
danemark de vendredi soir une bienvenue
meilleure expérience pour nous tous je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
madame je voudrais indiquer que nous
avons 25 intervenants je vous propose
deux fonctions suivantes par groupes de
dix
jeffrey dix premiers le président la
fois on fera les dix suivants et puis
pour le 5 derniers on coupera pas en
deux c'est compliqué en revanche
vraiment je demande aux collègues de
respecter les deux minutes si peu d eau
ministre également d'être concis dans
les réponses c'est la meilleure solution
sinon nous n'y arriverons pas aussi on
fait ça peut durer tard moi j'ai pas de
difficultés pas de souci monsieur michel
savin ensuite monsieur jérôme durain
puis madame jacqueline eustache brinio
puis ensuite monsieur lozach
monsieur jean pierre sueur
on va y arriver madame monsieur claude
kern
et madame marie pierre de la gontrie
et il est parti jean perrin on va leur
prendre la place de jean-pierre sueur
monsieur assouline ensuite
je cherche mes numéros qui ne sont pas
dans nos lampes rapidement monsieur
hugonnet et enfin monsieur paco bien
monsieur
ça va vous avez la parole
messieurs merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je tiens tout d'abord à
remercier les présidents la faune et
buffet pour l'organisation rapide de
cette audition suite aux événements qui
se sont déroulés samedi dernier lors de
la finale de la ligue des champions au
stade de france les images que nous
avons vues et qui ont été vus par 400
millions de téléspectateurs sont
catastrophiques et incompréhensible je
vais pas revenir sur les faits et vais
passer tout de suite aux questions
que je suis qui je l'espère trouveront
des réponses précises de votre part
madame monsieur et madame la ministre
afin de faire toute la lumière sur ces
événements tout d'abord monsieur le
ministre je voudrais avec évoquer avec
vous votre communication
10 le samedi soir depuis le pc de
sécurité du stade vous avez rapidement
tweeté que les incidents ayant entaché
cette finale était uniquement de la
faute des milliers de spectateurs
anglais sans billet ou avec de faux
billets vous avez par la suite affirmé
que 30 à 40000 spectateurs anglais sans
billet ou avec de faux billets étaient
massés devant le stade assez scar 30 et
40 mille supporters s'ajoutent
logiquement les 10000 supporters de
liverpool muni de vrais billets eux mais
qui à 21h n'étaient pas encore entrés
dans le stade si on bat si on se base
sur ces affirmations
cela signifie qu entre 20h et 21h entre
40 et 50 mille supporters anglais soit
plus de la moitié de la capacité totale
du stade étaient devant l'équipement
sportif le problème monsieur le ministre
c'est que cette foule immense personne
ne l'a vu
ce chiffre de 30 à 40 mille spectateurs
c'est votre chiffre monsieur le ministre
pas une image pas un témoignage parmi
les policiers d'oeufs et de nombreux
journalistes français et étrangers ne
corrobore votre étrange récit la fncf
que vous avez cités par exemple a
publiquement déclaré dans la presse
qu'aucun flux particulier aux plus
importants que d'habitude n'a été
enregistré dans d'autres sens après le
début du match où sont donc passés tous
ces gens
aussi monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur comme vous le demande le
président de la république et par souci
de transparence ou de crédit et de
crédibilité de la parole gouvernementale
je pense qu'il est sera facile pour vous
nous avez commencé ce soir à le faire à
apporter des réponses de bien vouloir
détailler avec précision les sources
officielles vous permettant de formuler
de telles affirmations et de vous
engager une transmettre rapidement
l'intégralité des documents officiels
dans des registres différents de
multiples dysfonctionnements étaient
contre ont conduit à ce fiasco en
audiovision crêpes deux erreurs mais mal
anticipé problème de pilotage du
filtrage et rattray dans le contrôle des
billets des dysfonctionnements qui
appelle des réponses rapides et vous
vous êtes engagés tous les deux à les
apporter de plus à aucun moment dans
votre conférence de presse de lundi
monsieur le ministre vous n'avez évoqué
les 300 400 jeunes qui ont tenté et pour
certains nombres réussi à pénétrer sans
contrôle dans le stade en débordant les
stadiers d'autre part ces bandes ont
ensuite agressé détrousser à la chaîne
était l'esprit des spectateurs
agressé avec une violence inouïe
parfaitement décrit dans la presse
internationale et lisible sur une
quantité de vidéos
monsieur le ministre j'ai deux questions
simples les multiples et méfaits de ces
bandes de jeunes ont-ils eu un effet sur
le chaos de cette soirée cette stratégie
de communication deuxième question cette
stratégie de communication de cibler
quasi uniquement les supporters anglais
at elle pour objectif d'éviter d'évoquer
ces actes de délinquance enfin dans la
même lignée vous avez souligné à
plusieurs reprises est en cours ce soir
que la france avait eu seulement trois
mois pour organiser cet événement majeur
qui d'ordinaire exige 12 mois de
préparation s'est donné les contraintes
étaient connus quand le président macron
est intervenu personnellement auprès de
l'uefa pour accueillir ce match à la
place de saint-pétersbourg monsieur le
ministre avez vous été consulté par le
président de la république comme
ministre de l'intérieur pour
l'organisation et la préparation de
cette finale en france merci une
question en madame la ministre monsieur
le président quatre minutes mon cher
collègue on va pas y arriver là je vous
la pose très appréciable le mieux c'est
de commencer par la question et faire
des explications éventuellement après
sur malte en monsieur du rhin
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre merci pour
la quantité d'informations que vous nous
avez transmises on a bien compris ce qui
s'est passé maintenant je cherche à
comprendre pourquoi ça s'est passé il
sait conjuguer beaucoup d'impréparation
d'improvisation et jusque là un festival
de défausse assez peu fair-play
d'ailleurs sur les supporters anglais
les clubs anglais les grévistes les
détenteurs de faux billets alors que
c'est nous finalement qui avons marqué
un but contre notre camp puisque
l'essentiel des défaillances sur l'aura
bien compris ce sont des défaillances de
coordination de filtrage de gestion des
flux de notes reçues pas lu ou pas
transmises ce qui me fait dire que
finalement en voulant organisée à la
hâte cette manifestation n'a sans doute
eu finalement les les yeux plus gros que
le ventre et m'amène à quatre questions
est ce qu'il ya un problème de
conception dans notre maintien de
l'ordre public c'est pas un sujet
nouveau on a eu l'épisode des gilets
jaunes ont pensé qu'on avait tiré un
certain nombre de leçons de cet épisode
manifestement non
le préfet de police at il des péchés les
bonnes unités sur place compagnie
d'intervention et braves sont elles les
mieux placés pour un certain nombre de
tâches qui leur ont été assignées
questions sur la préparation pourquoi
cette fameuse note dont maintenant nous
explique qu'elle explique tout ce qui
allait arriver n'a jamais été élu est-ce
que la djs et la préfecture de police se
parlent
troisième question elle tient la
coordination opérationnelle entre les
flux qui venait du r b rer d et ceux qui
venaient du rer b pourquoi n'y a pas eu
de réentrée orientation plus tôt et
pourquoi
s'agissant des délinquants qui se sont
attachés à dépouiller les supporters
n'at-on pas eu des forces pour
intervenir
dernière question
est ce que il est vrai que le dispositif
de sécurité d'accès au stade est
expérimental qu'il avait déjà été testé
pour la coupe de france mais qu'on est
sous une nouvelle organisation j'en veux
pour preuve un arrêté préfectoral qui
permettait de terminer commerce ce qui
n'avait jamais été le cas jusque là
est-ce qu'on a testé à la hâte sans
préparation un nouveau dispositif pour
un événement aussi important merci
madame lesage mourinho merci monsieur le
président j'ai essayé d'être très courte
pour les séries demande du temps et
collègues tout d'abord monsieur le
ministre grâce à ce que tout le monde
appelle le fiasco de samedi soir le
monde entier a pu découvrir
effectivement samedi que la seine saint
denis n'était pas la californie san
lameer contrairement à ce que disait le
président de la république récemment et
moi je ne me réjouis pas de ces images
qui à travers le monde aux données voilà
des images de la france extrêmement
détériorée je pense que personne ne s'en
réjouit alors le salut france il a
ouvert fin 1998 et la france elle a
changé depuis la fin de 1998 et lorsque
le président la république a
effectivement proposé que la france
accueille cette finale dans des délais
courts certes mais on le savait est ce
qu'il a été pourquoi nappes at-il été
mis sous votre égide monsieur le
ministre un comité de pilotage
réunissant au sein de votre ministère
tous les acteurs de cette manifestation
et je dis bien tous cela peut-être
aurait évité aujourd'hui de consigner ca
par marché de dire que ça les mieux
marcher demain par ailleurs je vous ai
beaucoup écouter monsieur ministre lundi
midi lundi soir aujourd'hui et vos
propos ont beaucoup choqué pourquoi un
tel déni de votre part de ce qui s'est
réellement passé pourquoi ne pas mettre
les bons mots derrière ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi ne pas dénoncer la
réalité de ce qui s'est passé et
pourquoi ne pas présenter des excuses
aux espagnols et aux anglais ça n'a pas
été fait et enfin je termine au vu des
images qui nous ont tous atterrés samedi
parce que ça nous rajoute personnes je
me pose une question le ministre
avez vous renoncé à restaurer l'ordre
public partout dans notre pays
merci madame monsieur nozaki ensuite
madame de la gontrie
merci monsieur le président bond et là
effectivement pour comprendre ce qui
s'est passé samedi soir et pouvoir qui
était responsable de quoi il y a eu
cette évidence et non de
dysfonctionnement de débordement d'un
prévoyant surtout quand on prend
connaissance a posteriori de la note de
la dnlh du 25 mai et encore on a très
peu évoqué la question de l'information
des personnes concernées une information
qui sans doute est avéré défaillante
d'où certains mouvements de panique
première question très simple et très
direct monsieur miné de l'intérieur avez
vous la certitude que le gouvernement
s'est donné tous les moyens et notamment
les moyens humains pour que la soirée de
samedi dernier au stade de france se
déroule comme une fête de manière
paisible tout en respectant bien
évidemment le cahier des charges imposé
par l'uefa en lien avec la fédération
française de football
car qu'on le veuille ou non l'image du
pays se trouve un peu ternie par cet
événement deuxièmement sur la bataille
des chiffres je n'ai pas y revenir mais
bien évidemment s'était mis le feu aux
poudres c'est votre estimation des
trente à quarante mille personnes sans
billet ou avec des billets frauduleuses
juste à la périphérie du stade de france
et c'est raymond boudon et expliquer
tout à l'heure mais quand on fait le
lien par exemple avec ce que dit le
parquet de bobigny c'est à dire je cite
aucune garde à vue pour des faits dit à
des intrusions ou de faux billets cette
mollesse je dois dire un petit peu
interrogatif un petit peu dubitatif vous
en conviendrez et troisièmement je
termine par le rapprochement avec les
jets si les grands événements sportifs
internationaux à venir de parler de la
coupe du monde de rugby des jo-2000 24 à
paris et pourquoi pas les championnats
du monde de ski début 2023 je crois en
étant qu'il faut pas tomber dans les
amalgames et comparez ce qui est
comparable
il est évident que la problématique de
la sécurité pour la finale de la ligue
des champions entre le real madrid et
puis liverpool ça n'a rien à voir avec
la sécurité des épreuves olympiques de
canoë kayak ou de tir à l'arc bon ceci
dit il faut quand même tirer les
enseignements de ce qui s'est passé
samedi soir d'où la question monsieur le
ministre est ce que vous envisagez de
faire évoluer de réforme et je dirais
globalement la doctrine française en ce
qui concerne dans la stratégie
sécuritaire pour ce type d'événements
afin de sortir d'une image qui est très
souvent une image du tout répressif
merci madame marie pierre de la gontrie
et ensuite monsieur clockers
merci président
2-2 question de demande
vous avez évoqué la coordination enfin
en écoutant les chantiers qui était à
venir mais pourrait-on avoir des
informations concernant la coordination
qui a été mise en place en amont entre
les différents services on a vu qu
effectivement l'épisode de cette note
fantôme montre que sans doute il ya une
difficulté travail collectif mais dans
quelle mesure risque donc ans se sont
coordonnés les différents services les
différents intervenants y compris le
stade de france la ratp la fédération
française etc et peut-on en avoir les
comptes rendus de manière à ce qu'on
puisse avoir connaissance du fait que
cette situation a été sérieusement
préparer et anticiper
la deuxième chose qui est donc une
question et une demande c'est que après
vous avoir écouté longuement nous savons
toujours pas où sont passés les 30000
personnes
qui sont censées avoir causé les la
situation que nous avons connue vous
avez regretté car vous êtes quelqu'un de
malicieux le fait de ne pas pouvoir
avoir de disposition des drones mais
vous aviez d'abord des caméras de
vidéosurveillance et vous aviez un
hélicoptère qui survolait la zone et
donc cela doit être possible de la
reconnaissance de ces images je pense
que vous avez tout intérêt parce
qu'effectivement c'est comme ça on a
l'impression les français ont
l'impression qu'on leur raconter ce
qu'on appelle des carabistouilles et
donc montrer ces images de prise par
l'hélicoptère et nous pourrons voir de
manière précise les flux de personnes
qui ont ou non circuler car vous l'avez
peu dit je rappelle que la fan zone
anglaise était plein et qu'il y avait
donc quarante mille anglais qui étaient
dans le 12e arrondissement entre la
place sur le cours de vincennes entre la
place de la nation et la porte de
vincennes donc il ne pouvait pas être à
la fois là et autour du stade de france
visioconférence
oui merci monsieur le président
de cette audition madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre
je vais donc aller à l'essentiel et
surtout à l'avenir puisque beaucoup de
questions déjà été posée et moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que je suite aux
événements catastrophiques
le samedi choix en tant que co
rapporteur avec david assouline de la
mission d'information suivie
l'organisation des jo-2020 cas la
question sécurité devient préoccupante
voire inquiétant va falloir assurer la
sécurité des sportifs les organisateurs
les officiels des personnalités des
journalistes des supporters en très
grand nombre et ceci sur différents
sites et plusieurs sites à la fois sans
parler de la cérémonie d'ouverture
évoquée par le président laurent lafon
la problématique est donc autrement plus
complexe à prêter
je suppose que cette question a été
évoquée avec le cojo et le job et le cio
également et j'espère qu'elle sera à
nouveau ouvert vous nous en dire un peu
plus et surtout envisagez-vous une
nouvelle procédure à mettre en oeuvre
suite aux événements de samedi soir et
éventuellement qui sera associé à cette
réflexion
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur david assouline et ensuite
l'est merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre 1 la
france est un grand pays d'accueil des
événements sportifs faut qu'on le dise
tous ici parce que c'est aussi à nous de
défendre cette image et ce savoir-faire
en 2016 nous avons organisé les
championnats d'europe de foot ça se
rapproche puisqu'il s'agit du même sport
c'est beaucoup plus de monde et sur une
beaucoup plus longues périodes en france
et en région parisienne
à ce moment là nous étions en vague
d'attentats terroristes
et à part les incidents qui ont eu lieu
à marseille
ça a était une organisation parfaite
avec à peu près les mêmes acteurs y
compris en terme d' organisateur lui est
fin et c'est
donc c'est pas nos fonctionnaires
c'est pas tous ceux qui se dédie à cet
accueil personnel hôtelier éboueurs qui
passe derrière pour nettoyer on en sait
quelque chose à paris
qui sont en cause ni le savoir-faire de
ceux qui sont en charge la france est un
grand pays
mais bien une question de pilotage bien
une question de
pilotage conjoncturelle d'un événement
qui a la même nature bleus que les
autres que nous avons su organiser et là
ça n'a pas marché
alors j'en viens à la question qu'a
posée monsieur du rhin qui est la
question de la doctrine du maintien de
l'ordre alors la gestion d'un événement
comme celui là c'est pas que du maintien
de l'ordre c'est une un accueil
ce sont des familles ce sont des gens
qui viennent pour faire la fête pour
supporter est ce que il n'ya pas dans la
façon dont a été appréhendé l'événement
quelque chose de l'ordre de les
supporters de liverpool les anglais
égale hooligans et donc la gestion n'a
pas été la gestion de fait me et de
masses populaires qui viennent pour
faire la fête mais dès que des dérapages
ont eu lieu ou dépression eut lieu une
réaction comme ont réagi face justement
à des délinquants ou des hooligans et ça
renvoie la gestion de beaucoup
d'événements y compris de manifestations
revendicatives par le préfet de police
ces dernières années donc je pose la
question très concrète
quel on est ce qu'on peut nous dire
puisque vous êtes dans la transparence
totale vous dites que vous allez fournir
tout à tout le monde est ce qu'on peut
avoir la nature des bri qui ont été
faites aux forces de l'ordre avant sur
les dangers et sur la façon de réagir
est-ce que nous avons la possibilité
d'avoir le type d'ordre qui ont été
données au moment où les tensions ont
commencé à avoir lieu les heurts
notamment d'envoyer des gaz que vous
même vous avez constatés et que vous
avez demandé des enquêtes mais vous
pensez bien que ça serait un peu fort de
café qu'à l'arrivée on nous dise que
c'est quelqu'un qui s'est mis à tirer
tout seul parce que je ne sais quoi
alors qu'il n'avait pas d'ordre du tout
d'aller dans le sens de cette façon de
disperser au lieu de contenir et de
considérer que c'était d'abord une
manifestation sportive festive et
populaire merci monsieur assouline
monsieur hugonnet et puis monsieur bako
merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
même si nous vous auriez préféré un
autre baptême du feu je suis quand même
au nom de la commission heureux de vous
recevoir ce soir et voir que le sport
est enfin un ministère de plein exercice
après avoir été traitée comme la
dernière roue du carrosse dans d'autres
pays ces dernières années
ce mini c'est pas à vous que
j'apprendrai que pour assurer la
sécurité et avant tout il faut tenir le
terrain
or samedi soir hormis le milieu magique
du real madrid
personne n'a tenu le terrain
clairement la responsabilité de la
direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation la démo pc et je crois
engagés ou en tout cas cela demande des
éclaircissements ma question est simple
qui était
le patron de ce dispositif sans vous
faire injure bien évidemment en tant que
ministre mais le patron opérationnel qui
était le patron de cette opération je
rappelle quand même qu'en 2006 alors
certes ça fait un petit moment mais
s'est déroulée devant 79 1500 personnes
une finale de champions league à paris
opposant déjà des anglais d'arsenal qui
ont perdu également contre barcelone
déjà des espagnols donc on sait faire
j'entends par les doctrines de
nouveautés non nous avons dans notre
pays tout ce qu'il faut pour le faire
c'est un problème d'organisation
clairement est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler l'organisation de la démo pc
ce soir là qui tenait le dispositif
quels sont les rapports avec
l'organisateur et les stadiers de l'uefa
s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le président en question
s'adresse surtout à monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur qui n'est pas ministre
des affaires étrangères et donc ça peut
expliquer que ces propos étaient peu
diplomatiques vis-à-vis de nos amis
britanniques et donc il n'a pas
travaillé pour l'entente cordiale c'est
une boutade néanmoins j'ai bien écouté
on a tous écouté ce qui nous a dit il a
insisté sur le fait que trois mois pour
préparer ce type de
rencontre c'était difficile alors que
quand on l'a fait que ce soit en 98 en
2016 finale de coupe du monde finale de
championnat d'europe il n'y a eu aucun
problème à temps eu les yeux plus gros
que le ventre fallait-il faire ce test
entre guillemets après il ya deux ou
trois points très précis vous avez
monsieur le ministre beaucoup insisté
sur le pré filtrage près de la moitié de
votre démonstration concerne près
filtrage parce que visiblement c'est là
qu'il ya eu de grosses lacunes dans
l'ancien monde le prêt filtrage c'était
plein de petits points de près filtrage
manama ministre a indiqué qu'il fallait
peut-être mieux baliser réorienter faire
des itinéraires de secours je crois que
c'est le mans vous avez utilisé c'est
évident mais ça existait auparavant on
est tous allés au stade de france on a
tous eu plein de points de près filtrage
or comme l'a dit monsieur du rhin
visiblement il ya eu un changement voilà
du jour au lendemain on a voulu tester
quelque chose est-ce que c'était bien
adapté
concernant le dispositif policier tué me
vous avez commencé à faire un mea culpa
vous avez dit on a fait en gros on a il
y avait des gens pour du maintien de
l'ordre mais pas assez pour de la lutte
contre la criminalité vous avez donné
des chiffres 326 homme visiblement ce
n'était pas suffisant c'était d'autant
moins suffisant qu' il ya des chiffres
qui pose problème alors il ya les fameux
40 milles si on fait l'addition de tout
ce que vous nous avez donné il avait en
france entre 90 et 100 mille anglais
entre 90 et 100 mille anglais on adule
savoir la veille ou l'avant veille alors
deux choses soit il y avait cent mille
anglais si si vos chiffres sont justes
et à ce moment là on l'a su et on s'est
pas adapté à ces cent mille anglais à
ses cinquante mille cent billets dont
parlait la dnlh soit il n'y avait pas
cent mille anglais et la sépaq ans s'est
pas adapté c'est qu'on n'était pas prêts
eh bien je vais donner la parole au
ministre le l'ordre qu'ils souhaitent
pour des réponses des plus courte
possible avant que le président la faune
de la parole aux autres collègues
monsieur norman en jeu j'ai essayé
monsieur le président d'être si court
mais sans frustrer évidemment les
questions il semble cependant avoir
beaucoup répondu dans ma présentation
bas je le ferai bien volontiers
rapidement je veux faire de petit
rectificatif d'abord c'est pas le stade
de france je les dis par abus de langage
et la fédération française de football à
l'uefa crise des prêts filtrage donc je
veux rendre à la cda la stade de france
le fait que ce ne soit pas les
responsables mais bien la fédération je
les dis rapidement je m'en excuse auprès
d'eux et deuxièmement je veux dire
également que avant imposition puisque
ce matin j'ai moi-même demandé qui avait
eu cette note de la tène la shdm a
répondu qu'il n'avait pas qu à 16h41 25
mai la dnlh a bien envoyé sa note à la
préfecture de police donc je fais moi
même puisque j'ai eu l'information
pendant cette commission on en apprend
le mea culpa toute façon ça ne change
pas grand chose pour une contenu cette
note mais non mais le contenu de cette
note n'aurait rien changé c'est ce que
j'essaie de vous démontrer que les
communiqués d'ailleurs à monsieur le
président de la commission et le
reconnaissant des documents évidemment
elle est tout à fait à démontrer pour
revenir à vos questions sur la
communication monsieur le sénateur je
crois qu'on n'a pas lu le même
tweet puisque vous évoquez celui ci que
celui que j'ai publié qui est encore je
vais pas mettre à rester dessus pour que
ce soit sur avec la blocs chaîne mais je
voudrais juste dire monsieur le sénateur
que j'ai dit des supporters des milliers
de supporters avec des guillemets pas
parler des dizaines de milliers à ce
moment là parce que je suis dans le pc
du stade de france des milliers de
supporters britanniques semblent il faut
bien ont forcé les entrées et parfois
violente et les stadiers à c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé voilà donc
ensuite il ya eu des informations plus
nombreux je veux dire des ramadam de la
gontrie qu'on peut discuter à l'envi
d'utilisation des images je dis moi même
dans mon introduction qu'il y avait des
images qui prouvait le retour pendant la
première mi temps pendant la première mi
temps et ensuite pendant la seconde mi
temps de très nombreux supporters
britanniques qui repartaient notamment
par le rd la sncf d'ailleurs dans la
note que j'ai transmise à votre prise en
détruisant des finances les banques
elles-mêmes simplement je ne peux pas
vous les montrer ces images moi je vous
parle de ces images là madame la
sénatrice saisir les images du rer
puisque je ne peux pas vous le montrer
mais je propose au présent buffet s'ils
le souhaitent à présent la faune de
pouvoir les voir deuxièmement c'est pas
à vous madame de la gontrie qui avait
suivi attentivement la loi sur lequel
vous avez d'ailleurs combattu le
gouvernement n'ont pas eu de pichot
utilisé des images aéroportée que ce
soit des drones des robots ou des
caméras installées sur des hélicoptères
à savoir que vous avez empêché le
gouvernement de pouvoir les faire voler
un renseignement deux ans judiciaire il
est un peu curieux madame la sénatrice
de reprocher désormais les conséquences
des causes que vous avez évoqué les
images notamment de retour puisque la
grande critique c'est le dire où sont
passés des milliers de supporters ou
deux personnes qui étaient autour du
stade de france ils sont disparus je
propose monsieur le sénateur si vous ne
croyez pas aux milliers de personnes qui
sont repartis cas sncf elle-même évoque
pendant la mi-temps et retour je vais
présenter je crois un tableau assez
clair et qui sera public vers vous
pouvez regarder je vais proposer au
président de regarder évidemment cesser
ces sujets et ses images auprès des
caméras de vidéo protection qui
démontreront que dès la mi temps un vrai
qui est un peu étonnant donc que des
supporters des habitants repartent du
stade ayant été au stade je les ai pas
vus partir voilà le deuxième sujet celui
de la délinquance bon j'entends bien
la question alors évidemment est-ce que
je connais à caen il me semble que
depuis deux ans je la condamne et je la
condamne fortement est ce qu'on aurait
pu lutter davantage contre la
délinquance évidemment pourquoi cette
délinquance a été de façon plus
importante que dans les autres matches
je pense avoir expliqué c'est parce que
le dispositif de sécurité hors public a
été levée notamment pour pouvoir sauver
des vies qui consistait à l'écrasement
aux débordements des personnes
extrêmement nombreuses parce qu en
surnombre et parce qu'avec des faux
billets ou parce que son billet qui se
présentait la décision prise par la
préfecture de police à sauver des vies
la conséquence a en effet été le livret
le terrain comme vous dites monsieur le
sénateur à une délinquance que les
policiers appellent d'opportunité je les
ai évoqué
je les dis je n'ai pas à le cacher il
est difficile de la mesurer complètement
sert pour ça que dans une formule tout à
fait originale est tout à fait novatrice
nous proposons à chacune et à chacun de
pouvoir déposer plainte et compris la
part de citoyens qui n'est pas dans
notre pays qui ne sont pas aux autres
pays qui sont repartis donc
effectivement il ya eu cette difficulté
mais je trouve que à la fin de la partie
la sénatrice êtes vous-même de
qu'évoquer avec beaucoup d' insulte la
seine saint denis et qui depuis
plusieurs heures voire plusieurs jours
évoque une essentialisation la
délinquance en évoquant des nationalités
en mettant en pâture un certain nombre
de liens très nauséabond qui font
malheureusement l'écho d'une campagne
présidentielle que pourtant les
extrémistes ont perdu je la trouve pas
cela est extrêmement déplacé je vous le
dis comme je le pense je vous dis
exactement comme je le pense si si je
pense qu'il ya une norme et il faut
assumer le fait qu'il ya une forme il ya
une forme manifeste quand vous dites
madame que depuis 4 à 18 la france n'est
plus la même et cassany a changé vous
faites le jeu je crois de partie assez
extrêmes et je veux dire ici
je veux dire je veux dire madame que je
suis personnellement mais j'ai mon
endroit et mon opinion j'ai le droit
d'être d'être assez choqué par ce point
et je n'ai pas et puisqu'on m'a forcé à
le faire pour lutter contre l'effet que
nous a donné des nationalités des
personnes que nous interpellons et je
suis d'ailleurs j'imagine que la
prochaine question sera quel type de
français avant nous interpeller mais je
n'ai pas encore cette question à ce
niveau mais je m'y attendais bien
évidemment je veux dire cependant que
sur les interpellations qui ont
e la justice poursuit ces personnes et
quand on me dit il n'y a pas eu de
citoyens britanniques de 6,1 pour
intrusion ou pour faux billets qui ont
été mis en garde à vue d'abord on a
présenté 14 citoyens britanniques pour
les intrusions à la justice c'est normal
de les relâcher si j'ose dire ce qu'ils
apprenaient leur train ou l'avion ou la
voiture le soir même je sais que c'est
pas moi qui les relâchent sains vous
êtes au courant que ces autorités
judiciaires qu'il de fait et
deuxièmement quand vous n'y a pas de
gens qui ont été arrêtés pour des faux
billets c'est pas vrai il ya des gens
qui ont été porteurs de faux billets en
grand nombre qui ont été interpellées et
d'ailleurs ça fait l'écho aux articles
de presse sans aucune espèce de
discrétion mais surtout les policiers
d'ordre public ils n'interviennent pas
les gens quand ils ont un faux billets
quand on est policier d'ordre public ou
gendarmes mobiles et qu'on a en face de
soi une foule de milliers de personnes
qui force et notamment dans des prés
filtrage qui sont faits par des stadiers
d'abord c'est pas le policier qui
constate le faux billets c'est bien la
personne qui embauchent et agents de
sécurité privés lust alliés donc il ne
peut pas à interpeller quelqu'un qui a
un faux billets je veux dire skali la
fédération française de football madame
la mise pour emporter témoins dans la
réunion de riz texte du mali matin c'est
que début il pensait même que des stylos
un chimiques qu'ils avaient livré était
faux puisque la quasi intégralité des
billets qui étaient vérifiées seulement
du côté britannique je veux dire que
toute cette histoire ne fonctionne que
dans les trois portes du stade de france
qui comporte 75 mille personnes et
comporte je crois une quinzaine de porte
ils ont tous cru que c'était faux que
tous les stades i o stopper l'entrée en
faisant remonter à la fédération
française de football que les stylos ne
marchait pas et d'ailleurs la personne
qui est en charge de ça nous a dit mais
on leur a dit que c'est pas vrai mais
ils ont même garanti 2 ans ils sont
venus vérifier eux-mêmes et partout
ailleurs les stylos fonctionner puisque
c'était des vrais billets et donc oui
les policiers dans leur public n'ont pas
à ce moment-là interpeller des personnes
qui a des faux billets parce qu'ils
avaient autre chose à faire il avait à
gérer une foule avec des enfants des
femmes enceintes des personnes qui n'est
pas la tête comme monsieur assouline est
donc en effet la consigne donnée à des
policiers dans le public c'est pas
d'arrêter des gens qui avaient des faux
billets c'est de gérer une foule je
l'assumé bien volontiers et si c'est ça
la faute qu'a fait la police nationale
gendarmerie c'est une faute que l'on
peut rien renier mais en tout cas
contraire aux règles d'emploi d'emploi
je veux dire évidemment on me répond ah
monsieur du rhin qu' il n'y a pas eu
d'expérimentation nouvelle dans cet
ordre public s'y est dans cette
organisation là je veux dire d'ailleurs
que la billetterie que le contrôle des
billets que la diffusion des billets que
l'entrée du stade n'est pas la
responsabilité vous le savez bien détail
ministère de l'intérieur donc il ya
d'autres autorités que vous pourriez
tout à fait si vous le souhaitez bien
évidemment auditionné ce qui a été
changée je les dis c'est une décision
qui a été prise par l'organisateur comme
c'était le cas pour la coupe de france
de faire des prêts filtrage au début
mais qui avait montré son intérêt pour
la coupe de france pour éviter justement
des personnes trop nombreuses qui était
pour ceux qui ont déjà été au stade en
tant que simple spectateur à l'entrée
des dix quais donc on peut comprendre
cette dessine au stade de france elle a
connu cette décision difficulté du fait
que évidemment seul le rer d grosso modo
apporter un maximum de monde concentré
pas de chance sur les virages anglais
fanta pareil c'est un virage espagnol le
rer d on aurait eu de façon disent très
différente ces problèmes
et troisièmement devant des faux billets
extrêmement nombreux parce que papier
personne n'a dit dans ses interventions
mais je réussis le répéter le fait
extrêmement troublant quand même que
l'intégrité sébile soit en papier alors
que toute la compétition est un billet
électronique et que la plupart de nos
compositions sont tombés électronique je
ferme la parenthèse effectivement il ya
eu ce nouveau prêt filtrage mais qui
était nouveau au sens depuis la coupe de
france il a très bien marché coupe de
france et là il a permis sans doute un
autre drame parce que c'est plus près
filtrage ces dizaines de milliers de
personnes avec des vrais avec des faux
ou sans tickets seraient venus de façon
extrêmement nombreuse directement vers
les portiques de sécurité et sans doute
que les intrusions ont été extrêmement
massive et sans doute que le match
n'aurait pas eu lieu puisqu'il rue
envahissement de terrain plus que
quiconque resté au stade de france va
que les grilles on les voit d'ailleurs
sur des vidéos ne sont pas très grandes
qui est très facile quand on est
extrêmement nombreux et qu'on a débordé
le service d'ordre de rentrée très
rapidement sur le terrain donc je crois
que ce prêt filtrage organisé par la
fédération était une bonne chose on
verra le retour d'expérience la marche
et brakel de france et il a permis de se
rendre compte des difficultés que nous
avons eues mais c'était la deuxième fois
qu'il disait les arrêtés pris par le
préfet de police sont les arrêtés qu'il
fait de temps en temps et pas simplement
pour ce match et qui était nécessaire
pour nos amis britanniques qui parfois
comme d'autres supporters je ne veux
poser de questions à personne
diplomatique peuvent consommer de
l'alcool il est possible que les
supporters de football
singulièrement britannique c'est
possible aussi boivent de l'alcool avant
d'aller dans un stade c'est peut-être un
problème dans le public que nous avons
parfois d'ailleurs les notes le dise et
qu'est ce que nous avons fait nous avons
autorisé à partir de 18 heures la
consommation d'alcool dans le stade et
non pas aux abords du stade pourquoi
parce que sa force les gens à rentrer
dans le stade quant à 18 heures vous
avez un public important qu'ils peuvent
boire et qui peuvent voir peut-être
parfois beaucoup et qui restent à
l'extérieur quand vous interdisez à la
consommation d'alcool dans le stade vous
laisser des points de fixation à
l'extérieur et je reviendrai à la
question de monsieur assouline qui
prévoyait en effet buzz du club
liverpool n'est pas un club comme les
autres et toutes les notes de
renseignement le dise madrid je vous
rappelle la finale de ligue des
champions en 2010 9 exactement les mêmes
problèmes peut-être que c'est ce que
nous aurions dû anticiper je le dis bien
volontiers que nous avons connue en
france pourtant les madrilènes savent
organiser le match de football à grand
enjeu même difficulté de faux billets
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
également en dehors du stade qui
n'étaient pas dans le stade avec le club
de liverpool je rappelle à wembley dans
il ya quelques années exactement les
mêmes difficultés malheureusement il est
certain que le club de liverpool avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour lui il ya
plein de supporters formidable et très
honnête fait effectivement venir pour
les services de renseignement des
personnes dans la note de la ddh de
mémoire ce entre 100 et 150 hooligans
qui n'a pas eu lieu lors de ce match ci
mais on se préparait en effet à des
comportements différents que les
supporters madrilènes je le dis bien
volontiers on posera la question de
savoir si tu es d'une erreur et vous
avez raison de la pose et je veux dire
très rapidement également que sur la
question que pose et madame de la
gontrie du compte-rendu moi j'ai aucun
problème à ce que vous puisque vous les
fournir il a eu exactement cinq réunions
présidées par le préfet de police le 16
mai le 19 mai le 23 mai le 25 mai le 27
mai je vous passe
les horaires mais voulez vous les verrez
et il ya eu quatre réunions organisées
par le job c'est à dire le directeur a
terminé délicate a mis ça en charge des
événements sportifs auxquels le préfet
de police où la préfecture police a
participé le 4 le 27 avril le 5 et le 19
mai tant qu'il ya eu de très nombreuses
réunions c'est moi je n'ai absolument
rien pour en tout cas ce qui relève du
préfet de police puisque j'en suis ils
sont responsables on vous communiquez
évidemment à votre président et les
comptes rendus nous n'avons
effectivement rien appris rien à cacher
pour le 10 juin que je laisserais
évidemment madame la ministre elle le
dira je veux dire que sur les fans zone
désir qui me 40000 supporters
britanniques je pense qu'il faut tout ce
qu'on aime langage parfois je n'utilise
c'est pas toujours que des anglais c'est
alors qu'il supporte aussi les impôts le
nous connaissons tous des gens qui sont
allés supporter liverpool moi j'en
connais personnellement y compris dans
les fans se noue dans le stade mais par
abus de langage voyez bien ce que je
veux dire et je veux dire aussi à
monsieur paco dans la zone y ait eu
quarante mille personnes un cours de
vincennes tout est documenté pour dire
qu'il ya eu douze mille supporters
britanniques qui ont quitté deux heures
avant le coup d'envoi du match à 21h
donc autour de 18 19 heures et qui ont
emprunté les transports en commun et qui
sont venus en plus au stade de france
donc de dire que d'un côté hassan ii et
deux salles de france avec les jambes a
pas communiqué je rappelle qu'à zone est
ouverte depuis le matin je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le préfet de police a eu
à gérer depuis trois jours la présence
de supporters madrilènes mois et
britanniques beaucoup sur notre sol sans
que bien sûr il ya eu la fête et qui a
eu de difficultés particulières
donc je pense qu'on peut pas monsieur le
sénateur m exactement de dire ce qui est
autour de personne n'a jamais eu et au
stade de france là encore une fois tout
est documenté et je veux vous redire
encore une fois que les chiffres de ratp
la sncf de la fédération française de
football qui n'est pas sous l'autorité
du gouvernement les à quelques centaines
ou quelques milliers près et les
bornages de la connectique orange évoque
la même chose que nous allons je
terminerais me se présente des excuses
être long sur finalement les trois
questions
fonctionnel sur la sécurité qui était
responsable du dispositif
j'arrive réparé permettez monsieur le
sénateur le préfet de police qui était
en salle de commandement de la
préfecture de police je rappelle que
pour nous le moment le plus dramatique
c'était le post match avec un club
anglais des supporters chauffés à blanc
si j'ose dire qu'ils gagnent ou qu'ils
aient perdu est un rendez vous entre la
fan zone le stade de france et les
champs elysées donc le préfet de police
étaient en salle de commandement et le
directeur de cabinet je dis moi même vu
du préfet de police étaient au stade de
france et quand je suis moi même
remonter avec la ministre des sports à
l'opc sécurité qui est au stade de
france il y avait dix représentants de
l'ua soir des représentants de la
fédération les gendarmes mobiles les
policiers d'à p p les représentant
évidemment delà des opc souk au moment
du directeur de cabinet du préfet de
police et également préfet de
seine-saint-denis donc vous savez que
depuis la forme de bp il n'a pas de
compétence dans l'ordre public donc
voici les deux personnes qui commandait
ses services je veux dire à monsieur
paco que ne peut pas compter les choses
en disant qu'ils avaient
80000 et 100000 anglais et qu'on les
aurait pas prévu on les a évidemment
prévu les points de filtrage de la paf
démontrent qu'ils sont passés évidemment
par plusieurs endroits et ils ont
notamment privilégier la voiture et les
passages en bateau je pourrais
évidemment le document t on les avait
évidemment accompagné on ne s'attendait
à beaucoup d'anglais sur le sol national
on s'attendait à simplement ce qu'ils
aillent dans les fan zone et que se
gaver des billets aille au stade de
france notre erreur a sans doute donné
de peut pas voir que des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui n'avaient pas
de billets ou des faux billets qu'on
n'était pas au courant des faux billets
sinon évidemment nous aurions fait je
crois des choses bien en amont en
enquête directement au stade de france
alors cependant il y aurait-il des idées
d'itinéraires de recours vous avez tout
à fait raison est d'ailleurs l'une des
petites erreurs qu'a commises sans doute
l'autorité qui commandait le barrage
c'est que on a accepté le détournement
alors la carte n'est plus là mais par le
contour du rer d qu'autour de
18h50 et on aurait sans doute dû le
faire avant devant l'accumulation de
personnes mais je crois que ce qu'il
faut bien voir et georges en excuse bien
volontiers les policiers et les
autorités de la fédération française de
football je crois que pendant plus d'une
demi-heure les autorités notamment les
stadiers n'ont pas compris ce qui se
passait et que l'une des erreurs c'est
que pendant plus d'une demi heure on n'a
pas compris pourquoi ces billets ne
fonctionnait pas pourquoi les stylos ne
fonctionnait pas il nous faut et il faut
vraiment que les stylos et pendant un
moment ils ont arrêté de contrôle et
essais préfet de police qui a décidé
d'abord le contournement puis ensuite de
lever très filtrage donc je j'entends ce
que vous dites on peut tout à fait se
dire de manière opposée que c'est ce qui
aurait dû être fait plus tôt et c'est ce
qu'il faudra faire sans doute pour les
prochains matches il peut avoir sur la
regarder des grèves comme c'est le cas
vendredi des attentats enfin pas de
difficultés extra normal et on pourrait
imaginer que le clan ben immédiat ce
soit le contournement vous avez
parfaitement raison mais je veux dire
dans cette situation exceptionnelle je
comprends que pendant une demi heure les
responsables de la fédération et la
police de gendarmerie et du mal à le
comprendre ce qui s'est passé je me
rappelle encore une fois ni mort ni
blessé grave malgré évidemment l'image
déplorable que cela donne je veux ici le
rappeler j'imagine que s'ils avaient eu
un décès dans cet épisode les
explications n'aurait pas été bien
évidemment elles mêmes et les
responsabilités donc enfin monsieur
pardon monsieur président monsieur
assouline il faut réduire je vous avez
tout à fait raison je m'en excuse
vous avez parfaitement raison dans votre
question c'est à dire que vous avez posé
la question indépendamment dans public
dont je crois avoir répondu qu'il
fallait revoir ce résidence porte il
serait certainement et bien sûr que
c'est pas un match de water-polo un
match de hockey sur glace je vais leur
dire que dans les mêmes circonstances on
a fait deux grands matches du rugby
internationaux à marseille avec des
supporteurs parfois un peu dur oui s'est
jamais rien passé soit la france est
tout à fait capable d'organiser cet
événement nous tirons pas des balles
dans le pied en prévision de 2 juste
polémique électorale me semble-t-il
c'est aussi me semble-t-il fierté
nationale que ne pouvoir le faire et
vous est tout à fait raison quand l'euro
2016 les choses sont parfaitement bien
passé par le gouvernement de la
république et par ses fonctionnaires
pour avoir comme j'étais directeur de
cabinet dans sa mise et sports en 2012
préparez une des candidatures d euros je
sais à quel point effectivement les
français sable organisé et tout en
revient monsieur cazeneuve qui a su bien
organiser l'euro 2016 auprès de sécurité
dans les attentats que vous évoquez la
question que vous évoquez principal c
est ce qu on n'a pas fait une erreur
d'appréciation en disant accueillant à
liverpool
attention à tout le monde puisque nous
avons affaire à des gens je ne dirais
pas dangereux enfin deux cas qui ont un
certain passé est ce que c'est
sion difficile il est évident et toutes
les notes de renseignement le dise que
le kop de liverpool pose des problèmes
dans leur public n'ont pas tous ses
supporters mais une partie petite partie
de supporters est effectivement le
dispositif de sécurité qui a été mis en
place et un dispositif d'ordre public
important et que c'est une erreur sans
doute que d'avoir
anticipé un hooligan isme qui n'est
finalement pas arriver là mais je vais
bien sûr heureusement parce qu'une foule
plus oligan poser des problèmes
évidemment énorme mais chacun connaît et
comprend ce que je veux dire et quand
vous parlez donne des renseignements
comme concentrait pas inspirés de ne pas
dire tout et son contraire et parce
qu'on a libéré le dispositif d'ordre
public qui était sans doute même un peu
trop important peut-être par rapport aux
clubs que nous recevions je rappelle
encore une fois comment toute la soirée
aucun pré requis et madrilènes dont
quatre avec les autres nous n'avions pas
mis le dispositif de sécurité publique
qui permet de lutter contre une forme de
délinquance qui n'est pas structurelle à
la seine saint denis stade de france je
le dire pour éviter les fantasmes mais
qui a été l'
aider pour reprendre le mot du terrain
du fait qu'il y avait humilié et des
dizaines de milliers de personnes en
plus qui ne rentraient pas dans le stade
qui était étranger avec un seul rer qui
fonctionnait au casino quasiment pas et
qu'ils avaient de leur public qui a qui
est partie du terrain pour pouvoir
regarder grille donc sans doute pour
répondre à votre question monsieur
assouline nous avons une somme attendue
à liverpool a des problèmes
les problèmes ont pensé qu'ils
viendraient de l'hooliganisme des
mouvements de foule violent il n'est pas
venu de là il est venu des faux billets
voilà et malheureusement je vais vous
dire quelque chose on anticipera mieux
la prochaine fois sans aucune espèce de
doute et c'est sans doute une
explication je le dis bien volontiers de
ce qui s'est passé samedi soir merci
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
mais je vous demande d'être assez assez
courtes dans le propos parce que nous
avons encore un certain nombre de
questions et il faut que l'on avance
même la nuit peut-être simplement pour
étayer un la récurrence des échanges qui
ont eu lieu entre l'ensemble des parties
prenantes
la première réunion a eu lieu dès le 4
mars soit après quatre jours après la
désignation de la france comme et y
hôtes de cet événement dont je rappelle
que l'organisation était placée sous la
responsabilité de l'uefa c'est au total
jusqu'au jour du match une quinzaine de
réunions qui ont eu lieu entre l'uefa la
fédération de foot le consortium du
stade de france la préfecture de police
la ddjs les différentes parties
prenantes au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur ces comptes rendus ont été
produits et le ministre de l'intérieur
l'a dit nous n'avons aucune objection à
ce qu'ils puissent être partagés merci
madame je vais donner la parole à au
président la faune pour les 10
prochaines questions peut-être plus
d'ailleurs environ allons-y mais messi
président buffet alors nous avons
commencé par thomas dessus et ensuite
valérie boyer
merci ont bien qu un succès
merci monsieur le président j'ai une
question pour monsieur misé intérieure
et une autre pour madame la ministre des
sports donc je vais prolonger la
question de mon collègue assouline
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez évoqué l' usage parfois abusive des
lacrymogènes on en a vu et 400 millions
de personnes dans le monde ont vu que
des lacrymogènes ont été utilisés sans
discernement avec parfois une certaine
nonchalance en direction des supporters
qui étaient en règle qui attendaient
pour pouvoir rentrer vous avez annoncé
des enquêtes concernant les agents qui
ont le malheur d'avoir été filmés dont
acte mais question pas plus largement
sur l'usagé global de ces gaz alors ma
première question ça serait ce que des
sommations ou des consignes ont été
transmises aux supporters avant leur
usage et par quels moyens et en quelle
langue les sept comprendre si notre
police est actuellement capable
d'accueillir un public international
vous avez évoqué vous même un changement
de doctrine en matière d'utilisation de
ces gaz lors d'événements sportifs alors
moi je veux poser la question pourquoi
se restreindre à ces événements dans le
changement de cette doctrine puisque
nous avons toujours observé depuis des
années des abus du même genre qu'on a pu
voir en direct samedi soir dans des
manifestations classiques n'est-il pas
enfin temps de changer de doctrine dans
l' usage de ces gaz et de viser une
méthode de matin lord tourner plutôt
vers la désescalade
et puis ma question à madame la ministre
des sports lors de l'étude de la loi
sport nous avions échangé avec votre
prédécesseur sur la gestion ou plutôt la
non gestion des déplacements de
supporters en ligue 1 ces dernières
années notamment concernant la
multiplication des arrêtés préfectoraux
d'interdiction de déplacement est ce que
cette politique d'interdiction de
déplacement n'a pas abouti à une forme
de perte d' expertise de nos forces de
l'ordre en matière de gestion des
supporters allez vous engager un réel
travail avec les instances les clubs les
groupes de supporters et les autorités
pour ces quarts et sécurisé et maintenir
garantir ses déplacements de supporters
je remercie
le président messieurs ministre de
l'intérieur ma question s'adresse à vous
je me permet de
ne pas simplement là où aujourd'hui si
cette affaire a pris une telle ampleur
histoire de faux billets même si je ne
mésestime pas à leur impact mais parce
que des personnes ont été agressé et
détroussé la france désormais septième
puissance mondiale a montré ce que tous
qualifie désormais de fiasco devant la
triste évidence monsieur le ministre
après avoir ciblé les supporters anglais
vous avez ensuite évoqué une campagne
nauséabonde vous avez même reprise terme
en stigmatisant les collègues qui vous
poser une question alors je vais vous
citer des syndicats de police qui
s'exprimait de la façon suivante
donc citation que j'ai retrouvé dans la
presse je les cite nous n'avons jamais
vu autant de mineurs isolés il citait
leur origine regroupe les hyperactifs la
délinquance locale était aussi présente
mais ce n'était pas dominant du tout une
chose est sûre des pickpockets sont
venus en nombre pour voler du cash des
portefeuilles des téléphones par toi
même à des malvoyants ou à des personnes
en fauteuil roulant selon je continue de
les citer il y avait tellement de vol en
flagrant délit qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
interpeller tout le monde aussi
considérez vous que les syndicats de
police sont une campagne nauséabonde
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question visiblement le problème d'ordre
public et des majeurs et aurait dû être
cité en premier lieu
avant peut-être même les billets de
stigmatiser des anglais parce que ce ne
sont pas les faux billets qui agressent
et qui détrousse
expliquez vous monsieur le ministre la
quantité de vols et d'agressions puisque
visiblement la police dit qu'elle était
tellement de voix qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas interpeller tout le monde est
enceinte monsieur le ministre le figaro
relate aujourd'hui des agressions
sexuelles lors de ces vols et de ses
forfaits et aux abords du stade de
france si ces agressions sexuelles ont
eu lieu ont existé pourquoi le silence
si elles n'ont pas eu lieu pourquoi ne
pas justement dire qu'elles n'ont pas eu
je vous remercie merci j'ai recollé à la
marque et ensuite laurence garnier
merci monsieur le président
madame et monsieur le ministre nous
avait décrit temporellement les
événements de la soirée avec précision
et je ne vais pas revenir là dessus je
sais aussi le travail remarquable que
font les policiers gendarmes malgré
quelques dérapages des enquêtes ont été
diligentées
ce qui m'inquiète moi surtout si la
perception dégradée de la france quand
les images de violence de vols à la tire
sont vus dans le monde entier alors afin
que l'image de notre pays qui est très
attractif pour les touristes du monde
entier mais aussi pour les entreprises
qui souhaitent s'installer en france
soit restaurée il est absolument
impératif que événement planétaire
organisé en france à 2023 la coupe du
monde de rugby en 2024 les jo soit
réussie
j'aimerais un petit peu comprendre
plusieurs intervenants madame la
ministre l'a dit consortium stade de
france si l'uefa fédération française de
football préfecture de police ont chacun
un rôle bien précis dans des espaces
bien précis
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il ya eu un
problème avec l'autorité
coordonnatrice de tout ce que ces
entités et donc de tous ces espaces
puisqu'apparemment il ya des supporters
qui ont été d'un espace à l'autre
laurent garnier
provisions
oui
elle n'est plus là peut-être que
si vous mettre d'accord ce président-là
fond
oui merci une suprise en de deux petites
remarques préalables d'abord sur
l'expérimentation des contrôles de près
filtrage qui aurait été fait bien en
amont cette fois ci je suis pas sûr que
ce même si ce n'est pas sur votre
autorité directe que c'était bien le
moment pour expérimenter doute l une
telle chose deuxièmement sur les billets
papier même si là aussi c'est pas
directement vous est ce que c'était
est-ce que ça pose pas la question du
mode d'authentification des billets est
ce que vraiment il y aurait pas lieu de
d'avoir une réflexion plus approfondie
là dessus pour éviter ce genre de daken
troisièmement sur une évaluation du
niveau du risque
vous avez fait dit que la coupe de
france avait un risque supérieur
selon vos informations
franchement il faut même pas être
amateur de football pour comprendre que
la chambre ainsi que l'événement un
événement sportif majeur et d'autre de
la et qui fait 400 mille quatre cent
millions de téléspectateurs et qui a une
billetterie qui ai demandé qui est bien
au delà des capacités le stade pour
savoir que c'est un événement quand même
qui est par nature spéciale qui et qui
doit mener une réponse en terme de
sécurité adaptées enfin sur les vélos
sur l'analogie que j'ai fait pour le
précédent avec la championne sic de 2019
entre tottenham et liverpool je suis pas
sûr qu'elle vaille parce que
effectivement il ya eu quelques faux
billets mais ce n'était pas de cette
ampleur là et je pense que l'analogie de
ce point de vue ne peut pas être fait
mais plus largement monsieur madame la
ministre moi je suis frappé par
on a parlé de déni mais l'euphémisation
que vous avez dans vos propos et dans
l'analyse que vous faites de la
situation on a eu un événement majeur
est certes ce soir est un petit
rétropédalage mais exprimé des regrets
moi je serai anglais supporters de foot
jeu j'aurais payé mes billets mon
hébergement et je peux pas rentrer au
stade et je me suis fait voler et
violenté et on exprime des regrets moi
j'ai exprimé mes excuses mes excuses au
président de club mes excuses au maire
de liverpool et mes excuses au premier
chef à toutes les victimes de ces
personnes et je pense que mettre le
trouble sur les supporters anglais de
liverpool
quand tu connais l'histoire du club de
liverpool comment ils ont précisément
pris des mesures drastiques pour réduire
et supprimer le hooliganisme de laisse
entendre qu'on en est encore là je pense
que c'est mal venu et ça rajoute à
l'erreur d'appréciation qui est qui a
été fait à ce niveau là moi je pense que
on aura beaucoup de mal à
corriger l'image dernier qui a été
consécutive à ces événements funestes et
maintenant ça va poser effectivement
notre capacité à organiser de grands
évènements dans de bonnes conditions on
sait bien tout ce qui nous attend en
2023 et en 2024 et il est plus que temps
non pas nous tourner vers l'avenir
madame la ministre mais nous tourner
vers ce qui s'est passé pour bien
comprendre les causes et les corriger
rapidement
j'ai regroupé dans un suivi de l ex
président madame la ministre c'est le
ministre mais aussi en conjointe de
l'époque où 300 go bonhomme j'ai entendu
des regrets amérique lui pas très léger
et jamais des excuses et pourquoi pas
des excuses car vous refusez votre
responsabilité dans cet événement et
lorsqu'on refuse alors on comprend vous
n'avez pas l'entière responsabilité
lorsque j'en pense que c'est lui et pas
que voilà à responsabilités ça se passe
quand même néanmoins sur le territoire
français et vous avez une responsabilité
si ce n'est vous qui n'avez pas la
stabilité c'est le plaisant la
république qui a choisi bien sûr de
manière très rapide et certainement de
faire cet événement à saint denis vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure 18 mois en
trois mois je pense qu'il aurait fallu
réfléchir et c'est sa responsabilité
qu'est mise en jeu et lorsque vous
entendez ce ministre est dire à madame
jacqueline osty tel brio le faire le
faire parler et lui dire comment me
donner il ya des propos qu'on doit pas à
boire terry ang lee on ne peut pas lui
reprocher certaines choses lorsqu'il a
dit que le stade de france n'était pas
paris mais c'était saint denis on sait
il ya une personne déguisée en faut
porter on sait que le maire de liverpool
a ouvert une enquête en ce jour il
propose dans un ensemble de personnes de
venir sur le terrain avec à un jour
trois questions la première celle
intervention police est ce que ça a été
adaptée et proportionnée à la situation
parce que je pense que les gaz était
prévu pour dix l'igad et on s'est rendu
compte qu'il ait pas de légal la
deuxième question c'est que pensez vous
des réactions du monde entier sur cette
piètre image de notre pays et enfin est
il nécessaire de réagir de façon aussi
agressive à l'encontre de nos voisins
anglais parce que vous dévoilez depuis
le début uniquement sur une fausse
billetterie je crois que comment vous
donnez vous honorez veillez à vous
excuser parce que je crois qu'il n'est
jamais trop tard de présenter ses
excuses aux supporters britanniques
diomède si président est aussi en lui
demandant d'être le plus rapide possible
pour que chacun puisse poser une
question alexandra blanche au fond comme
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre je
souhaite vous interroger sur deux points
qui à mes yeux revêtent une importance
particulière premièrement concernant la
consommation d'alcool aux abords du
stade et la vente à la sauvette
l'article l332 tiré 4 du code du score
prohibe vous le savez l'entrée des
supporters en état d'ivresse pourtant
nombreux sont ceux qui comme moi
pourrons vous décrire ses ventes
d'alcool sauvages dans des bacs de
fortune aux abords du stade et je ne
m'attarde pas sur les barbecues
clandestins dans des conditions
d'hygiène déplorables une arrivée au
stade qui renvoie une image comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer très négative et peu
rassurante finalement pour les visiteurs
monsieur le ministre comment
expliquez-vous qu'à la sortie de la
pandémie des ventes à la sauvette
subsistent et soit tolérée alors
qu'elles représentent un danger est
fondamental pour notre sécurité
notamment pour notre sécurité sanitaire
deuxièmement ce qui concerne la lutte
contre la menace terroriste
comment expliquez vous que j'ai moi même
pu accéder au stade sans fouilles
préalables un mouvement qui ne peut
qu'inquiéter les futurs participants au
grand événement sportif et culturel de
notre pays enfin madame la ministre vous
allez ce matin elle citait le tweet de
notre président de la commission des
lois je vous cite donc craqué under
prêcheur c'est le titre d'un v6 de
sportifs pros qui est d'ailleurs la
seule limite est de toujours là repoussé
alors j'espère que vous mesurez et qu'il
faut parfois quand on est en
responsabilité c'est à la ministre que
je m'adresse aidons à la sportive
avoir une parfaite conscience de ses
limites surtout si on veut les élargir
je vous remercie alors
oui monsieur le ministre
je ne pense pas que ce soit la première
fois qu'il y ait eu une défaillance de
la ligne b avant un match important
et donc
en tant que francilien nous sommes
quelques-uns à éprouver que la ligne b
n'est pas d'une fiabilité totale
indépendamment des événements sociaux et
donc il ya quand même quelque chose de
surprenant au fait qu' il y ait une
improvisation sur sur le siège du préfet
lui-même semble-t-il bond et voilà pas
où on va faire passer les gens qui sont
qui sortent en trop grand nombre par
une gestion de flux complètement
inadapté
donc comme les jeux vont comporter
beaucoup d'événements en
seine-saint-denis qu'on va se retrouver
avec des sujets de surcharge en tout cas
de surpression sur les transports
publics du même ordre il me semble qu'il
ya quand même un retour d'expérience un
peu sérieux à faire là dessus et je
trouve un peu surprenant que ce point
n'est pas été vu auparavant
deuxièmement le sujet du traitement des
activités pickpockets
c'est forcément de la sécurité publique
et vous avez indiqué que des effectifs
plus importants avaient été prévus mais
est-ce que sur l'expérience des
événements sportifs antérieures où ces
phénomènes lui également
vous considérez que la méthode la
doctrine d'emploi de la sécurité
publique pour intercepter les cas de
deux pick pocket et donc pour dissuader
que ça devienne endémique est ce que
vous considérez que notre méthode à
l'heure actuelle sur ce sujet est
satisfaisante et est-ce qu'il faut pas
là encore
anticipé des événements où ça va se
reproduire et enfin un message aux deux
présidents je pense que nous ne
perdrions pas de temps à russell nous ne
perdons pas notre temps à recevoir dans
quelques semaines le préfet michel cadot
quand il aura fait son rapport
merci j'ai un collègue éric kerrouche et
enfin gering bâti
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur ma question ne s'adressera à
mes questions s'adresseront
essentiellement à vous d'après les
informations que j'ai pu recueillir le
préfet de police disposés pour
l'événement dont nous avons parlé toute
cette soirée de 36 unités de forces
mobiles qui représentent à peu près à ma
connaissance 33 33 % des effectifs de
ses forces nationales et il n'a choisi
d'en déployer uniquement 10 de ses
unités au stade de france
est difficile d'expliquer ce choix au vu
de la note dont on a parlé vous avez dit
mais c'est surprenant qu'elle n'avait
pas été transmise d'accord il n'en
demeure pas moins que qui a été mis au
courant de ce choix stratégique du
préfet de police est ce qu'il a été
validé par vous par votre cabinet dans
des réunions en amont ou est ce que il
ne s'agissait que d'une décision
personnelle dernière question
comment peut-on expliquer le choix de
déployer la brigade de répression de la
changeant l'ordre sur le stade alors que
cette baisse n'est pas adapté à ce genre
d'événement au détriment notamment des
crs on comprend votre explication avec
les faux billets qui peuvent constituer
une partie de l'explication n'est sans
doute pas le coeur du problème qui est
beaucoup plus pour moi un problème
d'anticipation stratégique
jérémy baky pour terminer cette série
question
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre depuis
samedi sont d'accuser excessivement le
club l'hiver ses supporters viennent
accuser les victimes mais aussi les
grévistes du verbe et même les jeunes
seine-saint-denis d'être responsables du
fiasco qui se déroulait au stade de
france monsieur le ministre vous avez
vous même pointé une fraude massive
industrielle organisé de faux billets
madame la ministre vous avez annoncé
qu'un tabou des chiffres de 30 dates à
remouillé de supporters sans billet ou
avec des faux billets soit la moitié de
la capacité totale du stade de france
qu'est ce qui vous permet vous en avez
dit un mot malgré tout de tenir bois un
sens de résultats d'une enquête
concrètes d'autant que tous les
observateurs au prince ont un caractère
marginal de colliers en atteste
notamment les personnes qui ont été
placées en garde à vue aucune de ces
gardes à vue n'a eu lieu pour des faits
d' intrusion frauduleuse ou de faut
oublier pire si ce chiffre s'avère
exacte comment une production
industrielle de cette ampleur jamais vue
auparavant sur un aussi grand événement
a pu passer sous les radars ne pensez
vous pas qu'il s'agisse là on delà la
question des congrès comme si dense de
la gestion purement sécuritaire des
femmes de football ces dernières années
n'y aurait-il pas a déploré un manque de
moyens de compris dans sa matière de
gestion commune flux de supporters dans
de bonnes conditions le plus effrayant
et au cours des dernières années je le
regrette profondément
mon père dire quasi systématiquement une
déplacement de supporter à 115
interdiction de déplacement à google
cette année pour 380 matches joués les
forces de l'ordre ont eu recours aux gaz
lacrymogènes y compris à l'encontre de
supporters de manière indiscriminée
disant parfois famille enfin vous
rappelle la gestion des manifestations
de ces dernières années dans ce cadre
équipe pas urgent de changer la doctrine
maintien de l'ordre et que ce genre de
situations de tension puisse être évité
et de préférer une désescalade à usage
de la force enfin quid de la formation
des stadiers on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
cet après midi ne serait-il pas
judicieux
de mieux les préparer de mieux préparer
c'est à dire ce genre de gestion de
grands événements sportifs à venir car
en effet suite à ces événements se pose
évidemment la question la capacité de la
france à accueillir des grands
événements sportifs de grande ampleur je
pense bien sûr à la coupe du monde de
rugby en 2003 ainsi que jose olympiques
de 2024 jour en masse madame et
messieurs ministre nous allons vous
laisser le jeu propose deux
représentations il nous reste cinq
collègues qui veulent poser question un
jour donné la parole aux twins et puis
les ministres répondront et on pourra
ensuite élevé l'audition sur les
d'accord thani mohamed soilihi qu'étant
visio
sénateurs de martin
madame la ministre pouvait sonner chers
collègues nous question tout d'abord à
vous mesdames la mini vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure
indemnisation de paix
dessus qu'ils avaient achetés de bonne
foi et des billets et qui n'ont pas pu
accéder au stade est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus où vous n'avez pas
encore de autour des organisateurs
deuxième question
nous savons que
c'est le club de liverpool qui a demandé
une émission de billets papier qui
avaient le pouvoir de refuser
c'est bien qu'ils auraient dû qui aurait
pu refuser ces biais papier et enfin
dernière question nous savons aussi que
monsieur klopp le l'entraîneur de
liverpool malgré les supporters de
liverpool elle est de se rendre en
france ou même non munis de billets
est-ce que vous pensez que cet appel
appuyé jouer dans la défaillance merci
merci madame casabonne je crois que vous
avez renoncé à votre question céder la
parole à monsieur dominati mala benbassa
madame brulin et ensuite le prix dans la
faune monsieur dominati oui j'ai une vie
nice d'abord vous êtes dans une
situation difficile parce que vous ne
devriez pas être avec madame la ministre
jeunesse et des sports seul devant le
sénat parce que le dysfonctionnement ou
le fiasco qu'a eu lieu la semaine
dernière c'est un fiasco général qui
touche l'ensemble je dirais des services
du gouvernement mon collègue l'a évoqué
c'est peu mais d'abord il ya une
défaillance des systèmes de transport et
la défaillance des systèmes de transport
ça fait des années qu'on la dénonce en
ile de france l'autorité des transports
nous sommes l'une des seules capitales
européennes où les transports sont gérés
totalement par l'état et s'est
totalement défaillant
evènement après événement est l'une des
questions qui se posent pour les jeux
olympiques
est-ce que nous serons l'otage des
syndicats des sociétés de transport ou
est ce qu'il y aura un service minimum
comme dans ce type d'événement ça
devrait être nécessaire dans d'autres
collectivités
deuxièmement il ya une défaillance de la
fédération française de football c'est
pas la première
je vous rappellerai simplement que le
ministère de tutelle devrait sur la
fédération française de football avec
plus de force affirmé régulièrement ce
qu'il en est je prendrai part derrière
exemple pendant locaux vides tout
simplement l'arrêt prématuré par rapport
aux autres championnats européens la
décision de la fédération française de
football je pense que la tutelle du
ministère de la jeunesse et des sports
sur ce sujet n'est pas suffisante et
qu'il faudra à l'avenir en tirer les
conséquences troisièmement madame la
ministre jeunesse et des sports vous
vous dites que vous attendez à un
rapport du délégué à
un terreau ministériel c'est très
sympathique mais c'est l'ancien préfet
de police le délégué interministériel
la jeunesse aux sports c'est donc un pin
ancien préfet de police qui va faire un
rapport sur les défaillances qui ont eu
lieu éventuellement au stade de france
c'est curieux mais c'est d'ailleurs il
n'est pas que ancien préfet de police
parce que nous les élus parisiens on
connaît bien il était aussi préfet de
région la dernière fois que j'ai vu
c'était justement pour parler du rer b
et surtout de l'action du gouvernement
pour faire en sorte que très rapidement
il y ait la liaison entre charles de
gaulle et le centre de paris au
détriment de la ligne rer a et b puisque
qui concerne tous les franciliens sous
prétexte qu'il y avait urgence urgence
il y avait une enquête publique et
urgence pour les jeux olympiques et puis
finalement quelques temps après à cause
du que vides le gouvernement a renoncé à
ses rapports alors les rapports je sais
pas ce qu'on peut en attendre en tout
cas je pense que pour votre ministère il
serait bon de prendre véritablement une
distance nécessaire à la suite de ce
crash parce que l'événement plusieurs
collègues l'ont dit c'est les jeux
olympiques et c'est l'image de paris et
si vous partez simplement sur certains
dysfonctionnements
effectivement c'est problématique c'est
la remise en cause l'étude du cras nous
intéresse c'est peu ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de savoir quelle est la
réaction du gouvernement pour modifier
les choses allaient venir est-ce que
c'est au niveau du premier ministre ou
est ce simplement le ministre de
l'intérieur la ministre de jeunesse et
des sports et enfin sur la police
monsieur le ministre
je ne sais pas si on a sauvé des vive la
semaine dernière peut-être vous reprenez
d'ailleurs les termes de votre
prédécesseur monsieur castaner lorsqu'il
disait que le préfet de police avait
sauvé des vies lors du
lord et negar sur l'arc de triomphe
c'est ce qu'il avait dit à l'assemblée
nationale à l'époque en parlant de
l'ancien préfet de police en réalité
vous êtes dans une situation un peu
difficile parce que depuis dix ans vous
êtes le huitième ministre de l'intérieur
depuis 2012 la durée de vie des
ministres de l'intérieur est inférieure
à celle des préfets de police
dont vous êtes si ça fait à peu près
deux ans que vous êtes en poste au
ministère vous êtes à la loupe d'un
quinquennat vous commencez à avoir de la
bouteille ce qu'on attend de vous ce que
moi j'attends de vous c'est les réformes
de structures se sont pas les hommes
parce que les hommes les effectifs on
les a les moyens ils ont été mis
dernièrement mais ce sont des réformes
de structure et la structure de la
préfecture de police ça fait des années
et des années qu'on en parle c'est un
serpent de mer et ça ne fonctionne
toujours pas très bien parfois ça
fonctionne c'est une institution qui ne
se sont pas les hommes qui travaillent à
la préfecture de police qui sont en
cause c'est la structure même dans la
police nationale de cet état dans l'état
et des événements de cette importance
doivent faire l'objet d'une révision
merci chers collègues limbé de bassar
et puis madame brûla ensuite et le prix
joseph ou robes à damas merci monsieur
le président comme comme vous le savez
mais mais ce que madame monsieur et
madame la ministre
les forces de sécurité intérieure ne
rentre plus dans les stades et pourrait
effectuer les contrôles tous sont
effectuées par les civils la question de
l'évaluation et de la mobilisation des
forces de l'ordre sur le parvis aux
alentours du stade des gares de rer et
sur les trajets retour revient à la
préfecture de police ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il faut s'interroger sérieusement sur
les consignes données par le préfet de
police aux forces de l'ordre et est elle
adaptée aux circonstances c'est une
question quand même qu'il faut étudier
se demander si les cons ce qui ne
devrait pas être plus réactive et
également plus flexible suivant les
circonstances là je crois qu'il ya eu
des consignes en amont qui n'ont pas été
je vu devant la nouvelle situation il
faudrait peut-être reconnaître aussi
cela et ne pas se contenter
d'essentialiser alors elle et les
anglais comme étant des dons légaux
possibles et sont enfin si je crois que
nous devons plutôt nous en excuser et de
ce qui était arrivé mais là peut-être il
faut arrêter aussi il n'y a pas de bon
spectateurs des mauvais spectateurs il
ya des circonstances des événements et
la conjoncture du moment merci messieurs
dames même si phil brûlant et ensuite
les présidents laffont
merci monsieur le président madame
monsieur le ministre y compris aux
qualités des conditions il me semble
qu'il y a quand même non pas seulement
un problème de disproportion entre les
moyens déployés en faveur de l'ordre
public et se déployant dans albert dess
sécurité publique mais un vrai problème
de nature
de la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
parce que même après vos explications
sur le ministre entendre que pour que
des des supporters ne se passe pas
écraser il a fallu utiliser du gaz
lacrymogène vous imaginez bien que ça ne
va pas être aisée qui tenait déjà très
inquiet de voir la situation que nous
avons connue ce samedi et ça paraît
complètement invraisemblable ensuite sur
vous avez beaucoup évoqué la volonté de
liverpool d'avoir de disposer de billets
à pied
qui vous semble vous mettre la puce à
l'oreille mais quelle a été la nature de
vos échanges des échanges de vos
services de renseignement avec ceux de
grande bretagne quand vous avez eu
cette connaissance
parce que vous nous retourner la
question en disant vous semblez faire
bien peu de cas de cette affaire mais
c'est quand même de votre responsabilité
si vous êtes à l'acte est sûre
sur le fait que des billets plus
falsifiable vont être mises en
circulation d'essayer de comprendre
pourquoi elle d'y remédier il a été
évoqué à plusieurs reprises et c'est
très juste la nécessaire formation des
stadiers mais je crois qu'il ya aussi
une question sur leur nombre vous avez
évoqué des comparaisons entre des matchs
récents par rapport à cette finale de la
champions champions league mais il ya
par le passé eu des stadiers en nombre
bien plus important encore et on sait
qu'il ya aujourd'hui une crise de
recrutement qu'il ya sûrement des
propositions à travailler en ce sens à
et enfin pourquoi ne pas reprendre un
certain nombre de propositions qui ont
été faits notamment dans le rapport de
marie george buffet de sacha oublier
pour mieux associer les supporters en
faire des partenaires à part entière de
l'organisation de telles compétitions je
pense que c'est absolument indispensable
et pour conclure je pense que les propos
qui sont tenus sur le club de liverpool
ne sont pas de nature à apaiser les
choses il ya effectivement des
supporters qui sont parmi les victimes
et qu'il y aura de nouvelles rencontres
avec ce club et qu'un certain nombre de
propos qui ont été tenus risque fait
d'envenimer les choses par la suite ce
qui est très dommageable merci merci
madame et je vais donner la parole aux
présidents la faune pour une question
qui ensuite lui-même donnera la parole
aux eaux au ministre pour une réponse
merci
les secours et vendredi prochains à lui
le made in france danemark au stade de
france dans des conditions en tout cas
du point de vue de l'accès par le rer d
un peu similaire puisqu'une grève est
annoncée
quelles sont les mesures que vous allez
prendre pour éviter les goulots
d'étranglement vous avez dénoncé tout à
l'heure et les systèmes d'amélioration
des gestion de flux que vous serez à
l'esprit notre dame la lys et qu'elles
sont l'état des discussions vous avez
avec la ratp sur ce point
nous vous écoutons non pour l'ensemble
des réponses
c'est pas qui commence c'est ce que
c'est une formule 1
je vais
peut-être démarrer donc un certain
nombre de questions ont été posées sur
le sujet du supporterisme je pense qu'on
a eu en effet un week-end au global
c'est malheureux puisque après nos
déboires de samedi soir
on a tous constaté ce qui s'est passé à
geoffroy guichard et tout au long de
cette saison de football en ligue 1 un
regain des violences dans les stades d
août 21 en octobre ensuite c'est
d'ailleurs aussi quelque chose ce regain
de la violence dans les stades qu'on a
pu constater en angleterre donc il ya là
une véritable problématique sur le
supporterisme qu'il faut absolument
qu'on adresse avec une détermination
totale vous vous souvenez quand sortie
de la réunion que nous avons eue hier
matin nous avons annoncé que nous
allions lancé avec gérald darmanin eric
dupond moretti un groupe de travail
conjoint qui permettra de reprendre ses
plans d'action avec toute l'énergie
nécessaire
avec une volonté de fermeté absolue
vis-à-vis des fauteurs de troubles mais
aussi de dialogue nous croyons en la
force du dialogue avec en effet les
associations de supporters et avec
l'instance nationale du supporterisme
dans les tout prochains jours j'ai
d'ailleurs une session de travail avec
sacha ollier et marie george buffet je
recevrai la semaine prochaine déjà l'une
des premières associations de supporters
il nous enclenchons ensemble sur cette
échelle interministériel et avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes cette
reprise en main de ce sujet de la lutte
contre les dérives et la violence dans
les stades
le régime de la loi du 2 mars 2022 ce
qu'elle a pu instaurer sur les fumigènes
ou d'autres aspects relatifs au
transport j'ai envie de dire c'est
l'ensemble que nous allons essayer de
regarder aussi bien les interdictions
administratives de stade que les
interdictions commercial ce régime en
effet des déplacements le régime
disciplinaire de la lfp les questions
également aussi par exemple de
billetterie plus nominative qui pourront
nous permettre un meilleur contrôle des
flux donc compter sur nous pour
effectuer ce travail et vous en rendre
compte
sur le sujet de de la billetterie je
voudrais préciser un petit point en
complément sur le supportérisme que j'ai
reçu tout à l'heure une lettre du maire
de saint-etienne gaël perdriau qui
précisément propose aussi que les élus
locaux soient très associée à ce
nécessaire travail contre la violence
dans les stades et prépare peut-être
ensemble et avec les communautés de
communes et communauté urbaine un livre
blanc ce sont ses mots pour contribuer à
la réflexion qui est une réflexion que
nous mènerons vraiment avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes
sur le sujet de la billetterie
oui nous allons nous allons innover nous
allons tenter d'ailleurs dès la
prochaine le prochain concert qui a lieu
au stade de france avec ed sheeran
d'introduire cette billetterie
électronique avec cette composante blog
shane qui garantit que les billets soit
1 falsifiable donc nous n'attendrons pas
longtemps y compris à travers d'autres
types d'événements que les seuls
événements sportifs pour avancer dans
cette nécessaire à l'innovation en
matière de billetterie
voilà pour cette audition
d'amélie oudéa castéra la mine et des
sports des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques et de gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur devant les
commissions des lois et la commission de
la culture d'éducation et la
communication du sénat plus de deux
heures et demie d'audition que vous avez
pu suivre en direct sur notre antenne et
que vous pourrez revoir à 22h merci à
toutes les équipes de public sénat
c'était l'évènement du jour